Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode involves a crime against children. It may not be suitable for all listeners. In Australia, Father's Day falls on the first Sunday of September. Every year in the state of Victoria, the Father's Day Council awards one individual with the
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心。关于保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。本集涉及针对儿童的犯罪。可能不适合所有听众。在澳大利亚，父亲节是九月的第一个星期日。维多利亚州每年都会在父亲节由父亲节委员会向一位个人颁发
prestigious Father of the Year award, a tradition held since 1956. A long list of celebrity top dads have received this recognition, but in recent years the council has focused on ordinary dads with extraordinary stories. In 2005, Dr Rob Moody was awarded Victoria's Father of the Year. As the chief executive of the Victorian Health Promotion Foundation, Dr Moody had an esteemed career in the public health sector. But for his two children, Nick and Penny, it was his role as their father that truly defined him.
备受瞩目的年度父亲奖，这是一项自1956年以来一直保持的传统。许多知名名人父亲都曾获此殊荣，但在近年，委员会将重点转向了有着非凡故事的普通父亲。2005年，罗布·穆迪（Rob Moody）博士被授予维多利亚州年度父亲奖。作为维多利亚州健康促进基金会的首席执行官，穆迪博士在公共卫生领域拥有备受尊崇的职业生涯。但对于他的两个孩子尼克（Nick）和佩妮（Penny）来说，他作为父亲的角色才是真正定义他的人生。
Understanding that not everyone is lucky enough to be raised by a loving father, Penny expressed her gratitude to her dad and explained why he deserved the win, stating, He's always there when I need help. On Sunday, September 4, 2005, far more humble celebrations were underway at a home in the Port City of Geelong. Shane and his partner were introducing the newest member of their family to their friends and relatives. The young couple had just become first-time parents, with mother and baby released from
深知并非所有人都有幸在充满爱的父亲抚养下长大，佩妮向父亲表达了感激之情，并解释了他为什么当之无愧地获奖，她说：“当我需要帮助时，他总是在我身边。”2005年9月4日星期日，在港口城市吉朗（Geelong）的一个家中，正在进行着一场更加低调简朴的庆祝活动。肖恩（Shane）和他的伴侣正在向他们的朋友和亲戚介绍他们家庭的新成员。这对年轻夫妇刚刚成为新手父母，母亲和婴儿当天早些时候才从
hospital earlier that day. Shane had an extra special reason to celebrate the occasion. It was his first father's day as a dad. Late in the day, Shane and his friend Tony returned home to Winchelsea, a small township 113 kilometres from Melbourne. It was only a short visit, as the pair organised someone to look after their dogs overnight. It was after 7pm when they started the approximately 40-minute drive back to Geelong via the Princess Highway.
医院出院。肖恩有一个非常特殊的理由来庆祝这个时刻。这是他作为父亲过的第一个父亲节。当天晚些时候，肖恩和他的朋友托尼（Tony）回到了距离墨尔本113公里的小镇温切尔西（Winchelsea）。这只是一次短暂停留，因为两人安排了人过夜照顾他们的狗。他们开始沿着王子高速公路（Princess Highway）驱车返回吉朗时已经过了晚上7点，车程大约需要40分钟。
Prior to construction that expanded the number of lanes and that at a grassy median strip, the roadway on the outskirts of Winchelsea featured two undivided lanes, one travelling each way. Little in the surrounding landscape has changed over the years, which in 2005 featured rural flatlands. These were primarily large, fertile pastures dotted with trees and the odd shed or dam. Shane drove towards a section of the highway that rose to a railway overpass, three kilometres out of the Winchelsea town centre.
在拓宽车道并修建草地中央隔离带的施工之前，温切尔西郊外的这条公路有两条没有划分方向的车道，双向各一条。多年来，周围的景观几乎没有什么变化，在2005年时，这里是一片乡村平原。这些主要是大片肥沃的牧场，点缀着树木以及偶尔出现的棚屋或水库。肖恩驱车驶向距离温切尔西镇中心三公里处、通往铁路立交桥的一段公路。
Suddenly, the car in front swerved around something. When Shane reached the same spot, a man leapt out from the darkness on the side of the road. Shane's brother had taken his own life months earlier. Suspecting the man was trying to do the same, Shane was compelled to pull over. The man, who was soaking wet and waving his arms, ran up to Shane. He was short, standing at just over 150 centimetres tall, with a stocky build and a noticeable paunch. He had brown hair and deep-set brown eyes.
突然，前面的车为了避开什么东西而猛地打方向盘。当肖恩到达同一地点时，一个男人从路边的黑暗中猛地跳了出来。肖恩的兄弟几个月前自杀身亡。肖恩怀疑这个男人也想做同样的事，于是忍不住将车停了下来。这个男人浑身湿透，挥舞着手臂，向肖恩跑来。他个子不高，身高刚过150厘米，身材魁梧，挺着个明显的啤酒肚。他留着棕色头发，深陷的棕色眼睛。
What the fuck are you doing standing on the side of the road, Shane asked him? Are you trying to kill yourself, mate? The man was frantic and appeared out of breath. His words were lost in an incoherent babble of rambling, sobbing and swear words. What have I done? What's happened? He kept asking. Shane told him to calm down, but the man remained frazzled.
“你特么在路边站着干什么？”肖恩问他，“老兄，你是想自杀吗？”这个男人情绪慌乱，看起来上气不接下气。他的话语淹没在一片语无伦次的胡言乱语、抽泣和脏话中。“我做了什么？发生什么事了？”他不停地问。肖恩叫他冷静下来，但这个男人依然心神不定。
He wanted to speak to a woman named Cindy. He told Shane to give him a lift back to Winchelsea so he could tell Cindy that he had just killed the kids. Immediately following his chilling confession, the man asked Shane and Tony for a cigarette. Baffled, they handed him a few. The man went on to explain that he'd had a coughing fit while driving, which caused him to black out. He believed he had done a wheel bearing that caused his car to end up in the dam.
他想和一个叫辛迪（Cindy）的女人说话。他让肖恩开车送他回温切尔西，这样他就可以告诉辛迪他刚把孩子们杀了。在这令人毛骨悚然的供认之后，这个男人立刻向肖恩和托尼要了一根烟。两人感到莫名其妙，还是递给了他几根。接着，这名男子解释说，他在开车时一阵猛烈咳嗽，导致他失去了知觉。他认为自己撞坏了一个车轮轴承，导致他的车冲进了水库。
He had woken to find himself submerged in water up to his chest. There were two dams nearby. The man couldn't point out which one he had allegedly driven into. Shane looked towards the nearest one. He could barely make it out in the darkness. The surface was smooth like glass as if nothing had happened there. Sceptical of the man's claim, Shane didn't think any of the local dams were deep enough to completely submerge a car.
他醒来时发现自己泡在没胸深的水中。附近有两个水库。这名男子无法指出他究竟把车开进了哪一个。肖恩朝最近的水库看去。他在黑暗中勉强能辨认出它的轮廓。水面像玻璃一样平静，仿佛什么都没发生过。肖恩对这名男子的说法表示怀疑，他不认为当地的任何水库深到足以将一整辆车完全淹没。
Shane offered to call the police or an ambulance, but the man refused. He and Tony also offered to jump into the dam to look for the man's children. But he replied, no, don't go down there, it's too late, they've already gone. The man continued to request a lift to Winchelsea to speak to Cindy. It seemed as though he mentioned her name at least a hundred times, but he was pointing in the opposite direction towards Geelong. Shane and Tony were equal parts unnerved and confused. They wondered whether the man was suffering from a mental illness or had made up the disturbing
肖恩提出报警或叫救护车，但被这名男子拒绝了。他和托尼还提出跳进水库寻找这名男子的孩子。但他回答说：“不，别去那里，太晚了，他们已经走了。”这名男子继续要求搭车去温切尔西找辛迪。他似乎至少喊了一百遍这个名字，但手指的方向却是相反的吉朗。肖恩和托尼既感到不安又感到困惑。他们纳闷这个男人是不是患有精神疾病，或者编造了这起令人不安的
story to hide the fact that he was trying to take his own life by leaping in front of oncoming traffic. Shane ultimately agreed to give the man a lift and guided him to the front passenger seat. It seemed that the man was unstable, Tony sat directly behind him so he could reach over and restrain him if required. Shane steered the car around and drove back towards Winchelsea. During the short ride, the man continued to ask himself, what have I done? When Shane drove into town, he turned on his car's interior light and realised he recognised
故事，以掩盖他企图通过跳向迎面驶来的车流来自杀的事实。肖恩最终同意让这名男子搭车，并引导他坐到了前排乘客座位上。由于这个男人看起来很不稳定，托尼直接坐在他身后，以便必要时可以伸手制止他。肖恩调转车头，开车返回温切尔西。在短暂的车程中，这个男人一直在问自己：“我做了什么？”当肖恩开车进入小镇时，他打开了车内顶灯，并意识到自己认出了
the man. It was a Winchelsea local who used to mow lawns around town when Shane was younger. The man's name was Robert Farquherson. Robert Farquherson was a born and bred local, having lived in Winchelsea almost all his life. For a time he'd had his own lawnmowing business, but by 2005 he was working two jobs as a cleaner. His friends and neighbours knew him as a friendly family man who loved Australian rules football.
这个人。这是一个温切尔西当地人，在肖恩小时候常在镇上帮人割草。这个男人的名字叫罗伯特·法库森（Robert Farquherson）。罗伯特·法库森是个土生土长的本地人，几乎一生都住在温切尔西。有一段时间他有自己的割草业务，但到2005年时，他在做两份清洁工的工作。他的朋友和邻居都知道他是一个友善的顾家男人，热爱澳式橄榄球。
In 1991, when Robert was in his early 20s, he visited the Winchelsea Hotel for a few drinks. There, he met 19-year-old Cindy Gambino. The two shared mutual friends and soon struck up a close friendship of their own. At the time, Cindy was embroiled in a long-term, tempestuous relationship. Everything changed when her boyfriend died suddenly in a car accident. Robert became a huge support to the grief-stricken Cindy. He visited her often at home to check in on her, and even helped her financially after
1991年，罗伯特20岁出头时，他去温切尔西酒店喝了几杯。在那里，他遇到了19岁的辛迪·甘比诺（Cindy Gambino）。两人有共同的朋友，不久便建立起了亲密的友谊。当时，辛迪正身陷一段长期且动荡的恋爱关系中。当她的男友在一次车祸中突然丧生时，一切都改变了。罗伯特成为了处于极度悲痛中的辛迪的巨大精神支柱。他经常去她家里看望她，甚至在她失去当地超市的工作后在经济上帮助她。
she lost her job at the local supermarket. At Christmas in 1992, Robert suddenly confessed his love to Cindy. Although Cindy considered Robert a friend only, he'd been nursing a secret crush on her almost since they first met. He wanted nothing more than for them to be together. The two soon began dating and had a whirlwind romance. In less than nine months, they'd moved in together and Robert proposed. Three days after they got engaged, Cindy discovered she was pregnant.
1992年圣诞节，罗伯特突然向辛迪表白。尽管辛迪只把罗伯特当作朋友，但几乎从他们初次见面起，罗伯特就暗恋着她。他最大的愿望就是能和她在一起。两人不久后开始交往，并经历了一场闪电般的恋爱。不到九个月，他们就同居了，罗伯特向她求婚。订婚三天后，辛迪发现自己怀孕了。
The young couple were worried about their finances, but Cindy was pleased she had always wanted to be a mother. On October 4, 1994, she gave birth to their first child, a baby boy they named Jay. Robert was excited to have a son, and the couple built a house for their young family. As he got bigger, it became clear that Jay was a real live wire and a generous kid with a mischievous sense of humour. He grew up to love the Essendon Bombers footy team, just like his dad, and enjoyed playing the sport too.
这对年轻夫妇对他们的财务状况感到担忧，但辛迪很高兴，因为她一直想成为一名母亲。1994年10月4日，她生下了他们的第一个孩子，一个名叫杰伊（Jay）的男孩。罗伯特很高兴能有个儿子，两人为年轻的小家庭建了一栋房子。随着杰伊的长大，人们逐渐发现他是个十足的活宝，一个有着淘气幽默感的慷慨孩子。他长大后和父亲一样热爱埃森登轰炸机队（Essendon Bombers），并且也很喜欢这项运动。
Almost four years after Jay's birth, Cindy and Robert welcomed a second boy into their lives, Tyler. Tyler was particularly affectionate, always wanting to give his mum cuddles, though a hint of cheekiness was evident in his smile. The family joked that Tyler's motto was, have food, we'll travel. Like his big brother, Tyler loved playing football. As described in the book On Father's Day by Megan Norris, Robert encouraged this passion by purchasing expensive footy boots for both his sons, telling people, only the best will
在杰伊出生近四年后，辛迪和罗伯特迎来了他们的第二个男孩泰勒（Tyler）。泰勒格外深情，总是想给妈妈一个拥抱，尽管他的笑容中也透着一丝俏皮。家里人开玩笑说，泰勒的座右铭是：“有吃有玩，随遇而安”。和他的哥哥一样，泰勒非常喜欢踢足球。正如梅根·诺里斯（Megan Norris）在书中所描述的那样，罗伯特通过给两个儿子买昂贵的足球鞋来鼓励这种热情，并告诉人们：“只有最好的才配得上他们。”
do. By the year 2000, Cindy and Robert decided they'd been engaged long enough and it was time to get married. The date was set for August 26, and they were wed at a local church. Their third son, Bailey, was born on New Year's Eve in 2002. He adored his two big brothers and followed them everywhere. He also famously loved animals. A neighbour had given the family a pet cockatiel that developed a special bond with Bailey,
到了2000年，辛迪和罗伯特决定他们的爱情长跑已经够久了，是时候结婚了。日期定在8月26日，他们在当地的一座教堂举行了婚礼。他们的第三个儿子贝利（Bailey）于2002年的大年夜出生。他崇拜他的两个哥哥，总是走到哪里跟到哪里。他也以喜爱动物而闻名。一位邻居送给这个家庭一只宠物鸡尾鹦鹉，它和贝利建立了一种特殊的感情，
perching on his shoulder and eating cereal from his hand. Although their family was now complete, Robert and Cindy's marriage didn't last. In late 2004, Cindy decided she wanted a separation, and Robert agreed. The couple remained amicable for their three boys. Robert moved in with his father until he could find a place of his own, while Cindy continued living in the family home with Jay, Tyler and Bailey. On the evening of Sunday, September 4, 2005, Cindy Gambino was at home, waiting. She busied herself by doing chores, but when 7.30 came and went with no sign of the old
喜欢停在他的肩膀上，从他手里吃麦片。尽管他们的家庭现在已经完整了，但罗伯特和辛迪的婚姻并没有持续下去。2004年底，辛迪决定分居，罗伯特同意了。为了三个男孩，两人保持着友好关系。罗伯特搬去和父亲同住，直到他能找到属于自己的住处，而辛迪则继续带着杰伊、泰勒和贝利住在家里。2005年9月4日星期日晚上，辛迪·甘比诺正待在家中等待。她忙着做家务，但当时间来到7点30分，那辆老旧的
Commodore, she began to wonder what the hold up was. Robert was notoriously punctual. Where could he be? At 7.35, Cindy was closing some curtains in the children's playroom when she sighted an unfamiliar car zoom around the corner and pull up outside. Moments later, someone was knocking frantically on her front door and shouting her name. Cindy ran over and yanked the door open. Standing on her front porch was Shane and Robert, who were saturated.
霍顿·海军准将（Commodore）轿车依然不见踪影时，她开始纳闷为什么耽搁了这么久。罗伯特一向以守时著称。他会去哪儿呢？7点35分，辛迪正在儿童游戏室拉窗帘，这时她看到一辆陌生的汽车飞速拐过街角并在门外停下。片刻之后，有人在疯狂地敲击她家的前门并大声喊着她的名字。辛迪跑过去猛地拉开门。站在她前门门廊上的是肖恩和罗伯特，两人都湿透了。
She babbled repeatedly, I've killed the kids, they're in the water, he told her, I must have had a coughing fit and passed out. I woke up in the water, I couldn't get them out. Cindy began screaming, where are they? Why didn't you stay with them? She launched herself at Robert and hid him. Shane realized he had made a mistake by bringing Robert to Cindy's home. The entire drive over, Shane had been wary of Robert's claims, but now the severity
他结结巴巴地反复说道：“我把孩子们杀了，他们在水里，”他告诉她，“我肯定是一阵咳嗽然后昏过去了。我在水里醒来，我没办法把他们弄出来。”辛迪开始尖叫：“他们在哪里？你为什么不和他们待在一起？”她扑向罗伯特并打了他。肖恩意识到自己把罗伯特带到辛迪家是个错误。一路上，肖恩对罗伯特的说法一直心存警惕，但现在情况的严重
of the situation sank in. He and his friend Tony left to notify the police, while an incredibly distressed Cindy leapt in her own car. It sat in the back seat, directing her to the dam near the railway overpass. Stephen Moles was expecting Cindy Gambino to arrive at his home any minute. The plan had been for her to quickly duck home and collect her boys, then head to his place for dinner while their children played together. While he waited, Stephen cooked a chicken stir fry and chatted with his 18-year-old
性让他感到窒息。他和朋友托尼离开去报警，而极度崩溃的辛迪则跳进自己的车里。坐在后座上的肖恩指引她开往铁路立交桥附近的水库。斯蒂芬·莫尔斯（Stephen Moles）正期待着辛迪·甘比诺随时到达他家。原本的计划是她快速回家接上孩子们，然后去他家吃晚饭，同时他们的孩子可以一起玩耍。在等待的同时，斯蒂芬烹制了鸡肉炒菜，并和前来拜访的18岁堂弟亚伦（Aaron）聊天。
cousin, Aaron, who was also visiting. But the minutes ticked by with no sign of Cindy. The stir fry began to grow cold. Suddenly, Stephen's mobile phone rang. Aaron answered it, then handed it over to Stephen, saying, it's Cindy. As Stephen pressed the phone to his ear, he heard Cindy screaming. Rob has been in some kind of accident. The kids are in the water.
但分钟一分一秒地过去，不见辛迪的踪影。炒菜开始变凉了。突然，斯蒂芬的手机响了。亚伦接了电话，然后把它递给斯蒂芬，说道：“是辛迪。”当斯蒂芬把电话贴在耳边时，他听到辛迪在尖叫：“罗伯特出了某种事故。孩子们在水里。”
Like Cindy, Stephen was a divorced parent of three. The pair had become friends a year earlier when Cindy hired Stephen to lay the foundation for a new home Shane and Robert were building. Following Cindy and Robert's split, their friendship deepened. Although they had developed romantic feelings for one another, they were not yet officially together. Stephen wanted to wait until Cindy was officially divorced for that to happen. Stephen tried to understand what Cindy was saying, but the call disconnected before he
和辛迪一样，斯蒂芬也是一个离异并育有三个孩子的父母。一年前，当辛迪聘请斯蒂芬为肖恩和罗伯特正在建造的新房打地基时，两人成为了朋友。在辛迪和罗伯特分开后，他们的友谊加深了。尽管他们对彼此产生了浪漫的感情，但他们还没有正式在一起。斯蒂芬想等到辛迪正式离婚后才让这一切发生。斯蒂芬试图理解辛迪在说什么，但通话却中断了，
could find out where she was. He and Aaron jumped in Aaron's car and raced off to find her. While Aaron drove, Stephen called Cindy back. Through sobs, she managed to tell him the location Robert had taken her to. Stephen and Aaron pulled up at the overpass at 7.49pm. A section of timber and wire fence that spanned the length of the neighbouring paddock had been mowed down and was strewn across the ground. Through the darkness, they sighted Cindy running back and forth through long, wet grass.
他还没来得及弄清楚她在哪里。他和亚伦跳进亚伦的车，疾驰而去寻找她。在亚伦开车的同时，斯蒂芬回拨了辛迪的电话。在啜泣声中，她设法告诉了他罗伯特带她去的地点。斯蒂芬和亚伦于晚上7点49分在立交桥停下。一段横跨相邻牧场边界的木桩铁丝网被撞毁，散落在地上。透过黑暗，他们看到辛迪在湿漉漉的长草丛中来回奔跑。
She was screaming into her mobile phone at an emergency services dispatcher. Please, God, not my babies. Please don't take my babies. Please, God. That particular Father's Day started out well for Cindy. She visited Stephen Moll's early in the morning to give him some presents, an electric wok and a framed collage she'd crafted using photos of Stephen with his children. Stephen loved his gifts and suggested she and the boys come over later that night so
她对着手机里的紧急服务调度员尖叫着：“求求上帝，不要是我的宝贝。求求你不要带走我的宝贝。求求上帝。”那个特定的父亲节对辛迪来说开始得很顺利。一大清早，她就去拜访了斯蒂芬·莫尔斯，送给他一些礼物：一个电炒锅和一幅她用斯蒂芬和孩子们的照片制作的拼贴相框。斯蒂芬非常喜欢这些礼物，并建议她和男孩们当晚晚些时候过来，这样
he could cook her a meal in the new wok. She then took her son's 10-year-old Jay, 7-year-old Tyler and 2-year-old Bailey to her parents' home for a Father's Day visit with their granddad. The boys presented their granddad with a gift and he in turn treated them to biscuits and icy poles. Jay also had fun steering his grandparents right on lawnmower around the property. He loved offering to mow their lawn because it felt more like a game than a chore. As an added bonus, his granddad always paid him $20 at the end.
他就能用新炒锅给她做顿饭。然后她带着10岁的杰伊、7岁的泰勒和2岁的贝利来到父母家，和他们的外公一起过父亲节。男孩们向外公赠送了礼物，外公则请他们吃饼干和冰棒。杰伊还开心地开着祖父母的割草机在院子里转圈。他喜欢主动帮忙割草，因为这感觉更像是一个游戏而不是家务。作为一个额外的奖励，他的外公每次结束时都会给他20美元。
Next, Cindy drove the boys to Robert's father's house so they could spend some time with their dad. Robert had custody of them every other weekend. Although Father's Day didn't fall on one of Robert's allotted weekends, Cindy had suggested he take their sons for the afternoon so they could celebrate the occasion with him. The boys were excited to give their dad his presents, a set of saucepans Cindy had bought to help Robert set up his new home and a framed photograph of the three of them squeezed side-by-side on a sofa.
接下来，辛迪开车把男孩们送到罗伯特父亲家，这样他们就能和爸爸待一会儿。罗伯特每隔一个周末拥有他们的抚养权。尽管父亲节并不在罗伯特轮到的周末，但辛迪建议他带儿子们度过下午，这样他们就可以和他一起庆祝这个节日。男孩们兴奋地把礼物送给爸爸：一套辛迪买的锅碗瓢盆，用来帮助罗伯特布置新家，以及一张他们三人紧紧挤在沙发上的合影。
However, Jay grew upset when he realized he'd forgotten to bring a back scratcher he'd purchased at his school's Father's Day market. Cindy reassured him that they could give Robert this additional present the next time they saw him. They'd arrived at about 3 p.m. and Jay and Tyler ran in to see their dad. At two years old, Bailey was somewhat shy and wanted to stay with his mum, but she encouraged him to go to Robert. Before leaving, Cindy embraced and kissed each of her boys in turn, telling them she
然而，当杰伊意识到自己忘带了在学校父亲节市集上买的抓痒器时，他难过起来。辛迪安慰他说，他们下次见到罗伯特时可以把这份额外的礼物交给他。他们大约在下午3点到达，杰伊和泰勒跑进去看爸爸。两岁的贝利有点害羞，想和妈妈待在一起，但她鼓励他去找罗伯特。离开前，辛迪依次拥抱并亲吻了她的每个男孩，告诉他们她
loved them. Bailey approached her with his arms out for a hug. As she cuddled him close, he said, Love you. Cindy handed Robert a backpack that contained nappies for Bailey. She asked him to bring the boys home by 7.30. In reply, Robert simply nodded. That Farquhson stood by the side of the highway, looking vague and remaining completely still. A car pulled to a stop nearby and Stephen Moles jumped out.
爱他们。贝利张开双臂向她走来索要拥抱。当她紧紧抱住他时，他说：“爱你。”辛迪递给罗伯特一个装有贝利纸尿裤的双肩包。她要求他在7点30分之前把男孩们带回家。罗伯特只是简单地点了点头作为回应。法库森站在公路边，神情茫然，一动不动。一辆汽车在附近停下，斯蒂芬·莫尔斯跳下车。
As he approached, Robert turned to him and asked, Where's your smokes? Stunned, Stephen couldn't fathom why Robert would be asking for a cigarette while his children were allegedly in trouble. Stephen snapped. How could you worry about a smoke at a time like this? Where are your kids? Robert raised an arm and pointed towards the paddock, stating, In the water down there. Cindy stood nearby, still on the phone, crying and pleading for help.
当他走近时，罗伯特转向他问：“你的烟呢？”斯蒂芬惊呆了，不明白为什么罗伯特在孩子们疑似遇到麻烦时还要讨烟抽。斯蒂芬爆发了。“在这个时候你怎么还惦记着抽烟？你的孩子在哪里？”罗伯特举起一只胳膊指着牧场说：“在下面的水里。”辛迪站在附近，还在通话中，哭泣着恳求帮助。
Stephen embraced her, then raced to the paddock. Moving off his jacket and boots as he ran, Stephen scanned the dark area for any sign of water. Up by the highway, Aaron moved his car so it faced down the embankment. He switched on its high beams, illuminating the pitch black expanse in front of him. Suddenly, a wide, rectangular shaped dam with curved corners became visible. A few skinny trees stood around its border. Stephen waded in.
斯蒂芬拥抱了她，然后冲向牧场。斯蒂芬边跑边脱掉夹克和靴子，在黑暗的区域扫视着水的痕迹。在公路旁，亚伦把车挪了一下，使其面向路基下方。他打开远光灯，照亮了他面前漆黑一片的广阔区域。突然，一个带圆角的宽阔长方形水库显现出来。几棵瘦弱的树木立在它的边缘周围。斯蒂芬涉水而入。
The water was extremely cold. As he made his way around the edge of the dam, Stephen's feet slipped on the muddy soil below. His hands were outstretched as he grasped, hoping to find something. He dove into the icy water, his body aching with each attempt. Then and again, Stephen pushed himself forward into the dam's murky depths. He found nothing. The sound of sirens filled the air as first responders rushed to the scene.
水极其冰冷。当他绕着水库边缘前行时，斯蒂芬的脚在下方的泥泞土壤上打滑。他双臂伸出拼命抓挠，希望能找到什么。他跳进冰冷的水中，每一次尝试都让他的身体痛苦不堪。斯蒂芬一次又一次地把自己推向水库浑浊的深处。他什么也没找到。警笛声充斥着空中，急救人员赶往现场。
At 8.07pm, the first ambulance arrived, then two police officers from Geelong pulled up. All paramedics, police, and the fire brigade soon followed. The loud whirring of a helicopter's blades could be heard overhead as a rescue helicopter hovered above the dam, shining a spotlight down on the water. There was still no sign of the Commodore or the missing Farquas and boys. Stephen Mulls, who was soaking wet and freezing, was escorted away by emergency workers. Cindy wept inside a family member's car. Robert stood outside, his face blank and arms crossed as he surveyed the scene.
晚上8点07分，第一辆救护车到达，接着两名来自吉朗的警察也赶到了。所有医护人员、警察和消防队随后不久也赶到了。头顶上可以听到直升机旋翼巨大的嗡嗡声，一架救援直升机盘旋在水库上方，用探照灯照射着水面。仍然没有那辆海军准将轿车或失踪的法库森父子的踪迹。浑身湿透且冻僵的斯蒂芬·穆尔斯被急救人员护送离开。辛迪在一个家属的车里痛哭。罗伯特站在外面，面无表情，双臂抱胸，审视着现场。
Paramedic David Watson approached Robert and took him into an ambulance. He dried Robert off and wrapped him in thermal blankets before checking his lungs with a stethoscope. David didn't hear anything untoward. He asked Robert to cough. Robert did so, but didn't produce any flam. David noted that he was alert and lucid and exhibited no confusion. When David asked Robert to tell him what had happened, he replied.
急救员大卫·沃森（David Watson）走近罗伯特，把他带进救护车。他给罗伯特擦干身体，用保温毯把他裹起来，然后用听诊器检查他的肺部。大卫没有听到任何异常声音。他要求罗伯特咳嗽。罗伯特照做了，但没有咳出任何痰。大卫指出他很清醒，思维敏捷，没有表现出困惑。当大卫要求罗伯特告诉他发生了什么事时，他回答道。
I was driving home when I had a coughing fit, which caused me to black out and lose control of my Commodore, ending up in a dam, floating. My older son opened the car door, causing the car to fill up with water and sink. I then got out and flagged down a vehicle, went to winch to tell the police and my ex-wife. Robert explained that he'd had a severe cold recently. He'd had a persistent cough over the past few days, but had never blacked out before. Senior Constable Ted Harmon stopped by the ambulance and asked Robert to take a breath test.
“我开车回家时突然一阵咳嗽，导致我失去知觉，失去了对海军准将轿车的控制，最终冲进水库并浮在水面上。我较大的儿子打开了车门，导致汽车进水并下沉。然后我出来拦下一辆车，去温切尔西告诉警察和我的前妻。”罗伯特解释说他最近得了重感冒。过去几天他一直咳嗽不断，但以前从未昏迷过。高级警员特德·哈蒙（Ted Harmon）来到救护车旁，要求罗伯特进行呼吸测试。
He agreed and passed. When Constable Harmon asked what had happened, Robert explained that he'd experienced sudden chest pain, then blacked out. At 8.34 he was taken in the ambulance to Geelong Hospital to undergo a more thorough examination. Cindy was transported to Windchill Sea Hospital, where she was sedated and treated for shock. Senior Constable Rebecca Kasky was a professional diver with the Search and Rescue Squad. She arrived at the dam at 9.45pm, tasked with finding the Commodore. Some snapped twigs and broken housing from a car's side mirror on the ground indicated
他同意了并且通过了测试。当哈蒙警员询问发生了什么事时，罗伯特解释说他经历了突然的胸痛，然后昏迷了。8点34分，他被用救护车送到吉朗医院接受更彻底的检查。辛迪被送到温切尔西医院，在那里她被注射镇静剂并接受了休克治疗。高级警员丽贝卡·卡斯基（Rebecca Kasky）是搜救队的专业潜水员。她于晚上9点45分到达水库，任务是寻找那辆海军准将轿车。地上折断的树枝和汽车侧后视镜的破损外壳表明了
the point where it had likely entered the water. Constable Kasky dove in and performed multiple sweeps of the area. Eventually, her fingers brushed against some plastic debris and pieces of metal. She was getting close. She had been in the water for more than 20 minutes when her head suddenly bumped into something. A car wheel. Robert's Commodore was perched vertically with its nose pressed into the ground.
它可能入水的地点。卡斯基警员潜入水中，对该地区进行了多次搜寻。最终，她的手指擦到了一些塑料碎片和金属块。她快要找到了。她已经在水里呆了20多分钟，这时她的头部突然撞到了什么东西。一个车轮。罗伯特的“海军准将”呈垂直状态，车头朝下压进泥土里。
It was 28 metres from the dam's edge and 7.4 metres deep. Constable Kasky was facing its underside. She swam to the surface. Knowing investigators would be treating the vehicle as a possible crime scene, Kasky returned to the dam's cold depths to seal it. All the windows were closed and only the driver's door was open. As Kasky went to close it, she fell to child's head protruding from the vehicle. She gently pushed it back inside and carefully closed the door.
它距离水库边缘28米，水深7.4米。卡斯基警员面对着它的底盘。她游到水面。由于知道调查人员会把这辆车当作可能的犯罪现场来对待，卡斯基返回水库寒冷的深处将其封锁。所有的窗户都是关着的，只有驾驶员的车门是开着的。正当卡斯基去关门时，她碰到了一个从车内突出来的儿童头部。她轻轻把它推回里面，并小心翼翼地关上了车门。
Finally after midnight, a police SUV winched the Commodore out of the dam. Water gushed from the scraped and muddy vehicle as it was hauled to dry land. The bodies of all three Farquhusson boys were visible inside. 10-year-old Jay was lying face down across the front seats, free from his seatbelt. In the back was 7-year-old Tyler, who was also unrestrained. He lay on his right side on the rear driver's side seat with his feet on the centre console. Next to him was 2-year-old Bailey, who was tangled in the unsecured straps of his child's seat.
直到午夜过后，一辆警用SUV才将“海军准将”从水库中拉了上来.当这辆伤痕累累、沾满泥泞的汽车被拖上陆地时，水从车里喷涌而出。车内所有三个法库森男孩的尸体清晰可见。10岁的杰伊脸朝下横躺在前排座椅上，安全带是解开的。后座上是7岁的泰勒，他同样没有系安全带。他右侧躺在后排驾驶座一侧，双脚放在中央控制台上。他旁边是2岁的贝利，被儿童安全座椅上松散的带子缠住了。
At the scene, Cindy Gambino's friend Stephen Moles turned to a police officer and remarked, I smell a rat, there's something not right. Cindy didn't share Stephen's suspicions. When she was well enough to speak with police, she told them that Robert was a devoted father who would never hurt his children. He'd never raised a hand to them and had no history of violence. Blood tests showed no evidence that Robert had been drinking alcohol or consuming drugs. He told his examining doctor at Geelong Hospital that he'd been sick with the flu for the past
在现场，辛迪·甘比诺的朋友斯蒂芬·莫尔斯转向一名警察说：“我觉得有蹊跷，这事不对劲。”辛迪并没有斯蒂芬的怀疑。当她身体状况足以与警察交谈时，她告诉他们罗伯特是一个深爱孩子的父亲，绝不会伤害他的孩子们。他从未对他们动过手，也没有任何暴力史。血液测试表明，罗伯特没有饮酒或吸毒的迹象。他在吉朗医院告诉主治医生，他过去
fortnight. Two weeks before that, one of his colleagues had seen him cough so hard that he was bent double with his hands on his knees. On August 18, a local GP had diagnosed him with an upper respiratory infection. Robert saw the doctor again five days later, complaining of a chesty cough. His chest was found to be clear, but the GP had prescribed some antibiotics. Two days before the accident, another colleague witnessed Robert endure a 15-second coughing fit that was so extreme, she worried he was having a stroke.
两周一直患有流感。在此之前两周，他的一位同事曾看到他咳嗽得厉害，弯着腰，双手撑着膝盖。8月18日，当地全科医生诊断他患有上呼吸道感染。五天后，罗伯特再次去看医生，抱怨胸部咳嗽。他的胸部被发现很干净，但全科医生开了一些抗生素。事故发生前两天，另一位同事目睹罗伯特经历了长达15秒的极端咳嗽发作，以至于她担心他中风了。
The emergency ward doctor had x-rays taken of Robert's chest. They revealed no issues. Based on what Robert had described, the doctor made a provisional diagnosis of cough syncope, a condition where coughing can trigger loss of consciousness for up to 20 seconds. It was a rare condition mostly found in patients with asthma or chronic lung disease, neither of which Robert Farquherson suffered from. Shortly before 10pm, Senior Sergeant Jeff Smith and Senior Constable Rowan Curtis from Victoria's Major Collision Investigation Unit arrived to take Robert's statement.
急诊室医生为罗伯特拍摄了胸部X光片。结果显示没有问题。根据罗伯特的描述，医生初步诊断为咳嗽性晕厥，这是一种咳嗽会引发长达20秒意识丧失的疾病。这是一种罕见的疾病，多见于哮喘或慢性肺病患者，而罗伯特·法库森并未患有这两种疾病。晚上10点前不久，维多利亚州重大碰撞调查组的高级警长杰夫·史密斯（Jeff Smith）和高级警员罗温·柯蒂斯（Rowan Curtis）赶到，为罗伯特录取口供。
That father's day had been low-key for Robert. He'd worked a shift at one of his cleaning jobs in the morning, then headed home in preparation for his son's visit. He was in his bedroom when Cindy dropped the boys off in the afternoon. The two eldest boys had run up to him, excitedly offering their gifts. After Cindy left, Robert had taken his three sons shopping at a local Kmart. He'd bought Jay a new cricket ball and DVDs for Tyler and Bailey. They ordered KFC for dinner, which the boys were very excited about.
那个父亲节对罗伯特来说很低调。他在早上完成了一处清洁工作，然后回家准备迎接儿子的来访。下午辛迪把男孩们送来时，他正在卧室里。两个大男孩跑向他，兴奋地献上礼物。辛迪离开后，罗伯特带着三个儿子去当地的Kmart购物。他给杰伊买了一个新板球，给泰勒和贝利买了DVD。他们订了肯德基当晚餐，男孩们对此感到非常兴奋。
At 7pm, they quickly paid a visit to Robert's sister at her home. Then they all piled back in the car so he could drop them at Cindy's. Jay sat next to Robert in the front passenger seat while Tyler sat behind him. Bailey was next to Tyler in his booster seat. There was a bit of traffic on the highway, so Robert made sure to drive under the speed limit of 100km per hour. He didn't want to take any risks with his children in the car. During the drive, Jay complained of being cold, so Robert turned the car heater on.
晚上7点，他们匆忙去拜访了罗伯特姐姐的家。然后他们都挤回车里，以便他把他们送到辛迪那里。杰伊坐在罗伯特旁边的前排乘客座位上，泰勒坐在他后面。贝利坐在泰勒旁边他的增高座椅上。高速公路上有点堵车，所以罗伯特确保在每小时100公里的限速以下行驶。车里有孩子，他不想冒任何风险。开车期间，杰伊抱怨说冷，于是罗伯特打开了车里的暖气。
Soon, he broke out in a coughing fit. He speculated that the hot air from the heater had triggered it. The next thing he knew, Jay was shaking him awake and crying out. Dad, we're in the water. Shocked, Robert had replied, just sit there mate, don't panic. He claimed that Jay then opened his door, causing water to gush in. The car took a sharp nose dive. Robert reached across Jay to slam the door shut, then tried to unbuckle his children
不久，他突然一阵猛烈咳嗽。他推测是暖气里的热风引发了咳嗽。接下来的事他只记得杰伊摇醒了他并大喊：“爸爸，我们在水里。”震惊之余，罗伯特回答说：“就坐在那儿，伙计，别慌。”他声称杰伊随后打开了车门，导致水涌了进来。汽车猛地向下俯冲。罗伯特越过杰伊猛地关上车门，然后试图解开孩子们的
from their seatbelts. He couldn't. The three boys were all screaming. Believing the water was only shallow, Robert opened his door so he could get out and run around to free his children. But the dam was deeper than expected, and the car sank rapidly. Robert tried to dive after it, but failed. It was so dark in the water that he quickly lost sight of the commodore.
安全带。他做不到。三个男孩都在尖叫。罗伯特以为水很浅，于是打开车门想下车跑过去解救孩子们。但水库比想象的要深，汽车迅速下沉。罗伯特试图潜水去追，但失败了。水里太黑了，他很快就失去了“海军准将”的踪影。
He clambered to shore and flagged down a passing car for help. When recalling these events to police that night, Robert described everything as having happened so quickly, just a big blur. Both policemen noted that Robert seemed calm when telling his story. The only time he coughed was when he described the fit he'd had while driving. Robert didn't ask whether his children had been found. And Smith said carefully, Mate, do you realise that the children didn't make it out of the car?
他艰难地爬上岸，拦下一辆过往的汽车寻求帮助。当晚向警方回忆这些事件时，罗伯特形容一切发生得太快，只是一片模糊。两名警察都注意到罗伯特在讲述他的故事时显得很平静。他唯一咳嗽的时候是他描述开车时发作的那一次。罗伯特没有询问是否找到了他的孩子们。史密斯警长小心翼翼地说道：“老兄，你意识到孩子们没能从车里出来吗？”
Robert gave a short exhale before replying in a flat voice. I gathered that. Then he asked, I've never been in trouble before, so what's the likely scenario for me? Sergeant Smith and Constable Curtis were troubled. They compared what Robert told them about the accident with what he'd said to others and found some slight variations. At the scene of the crash, he told a police officer that he'd only suffered from chest
罗伯特短暂地呼出一口气，然后用平淡的语气回答：“我猜到了。”接着他问：“我以前从未惹过麻烦，那我接下来可能会面临什么情况呢？”史密斯警长和柯蒂斯警员感到不安。他们将罗伯特对他们讲述的事故经过与他对其他人所说的话进行了对比，发现了一些微小的差异。在车祸现场，他告诉警察他只经历了胸痛，
pain while remarking to others that he'd suffered a coughing fit. He'd also blamed a faulty wheel bearing for causing the Commodore to steer into the dam, indicating the car itself was responsible, not his coughing fit. There were also inconsistencies as to what exactly happened inside the car once it hit the surface of the water. Distinct actions had been performed in the vehicle that Robert failed to mention in his statement. The keys were in the ignition, but it was switched off.
而对其他人则说他经历了一阵咳嗽。他还将汽车驶入水库归咎于有故障的车轮轴承，暗示是汽车本身的问题，而不是他的咳嗽发作。关于汽车一接触水面内部到底发生了什么，也存在不一致的地方。车内执行了一些明确的动作，而罗伯特在口供中却没有提及。钥匙在点火开关里，但它是关闭的。
The handbrake was also secured in position. The heater, which Robert believed had caused his coughing fit, was not on. Neither were the car's headlights. All of this was strange. The headlights in particular would have been on when Robert was driving, and if they remained on, they would have facilitated the search for the car. As for the other actions, if the accident was as unexpected and urgent as Robert claimed, why would anyone have the time or cause to turn these things off?
手刹也固定在原位。罗伯特认为是它引发咳嗽的暖气并没有开。汽车的大灯也没有开。所有这些都很奇怪。尤其是大灯，罗伯特开车时本应该是开着的，如果它们一直开着，本可以有助于搜寻汽车。至于其他操作，如果事故像罗伯特所说的那样突发且紧急，为什么会有人有时间和理由把这些东西关掉呢？
Police were also having trouble matching his statements with the physical evidence at the scene. Investigators from Victoria's Major Collision Investigation Unit had inspected the area in the clear light of day. The stretch of highway where Robert had veered off the road was smooth and straight, with no sharp corners or bends. There was nothing on the bitumen that would cause a car to unexpectedly skid off the road. In some roadside gravel, rolling tyre prints could be seen leaving the road.
警方也一直在努力将他的供词与现场的物证进行匹配。维多利亚州重大碰撞调查组的调查人员在光天化日之下检查了该地区。罗伯特偏离道路的那段公路平坦笔直，没有急转弯或弯道。沥青路面上没有任何会导致汽车意外滑出路面的东西。在一些路边碎石上，可以看到滚动轮胎离开公路的印记。
There were also visible wheel tracks along the grassy embankment leading into the water. And squad investigators estimated that in order to land in the dam, the car must have turned right at an angle of approximately 30 degrees. It then crossed over the opposite lane, crashed through the wire fence, continued driving through the grassy embankment and scraped a tree on its left before arriving in the water. The distance from the edge of the road to the dam was 44 metres. The path travelled by the car had been clear and direct. Police couldn't find anything that indicated Robert had lost control of his vehicle.
沿着通往水库的草地路基也能看到清晰的车辙。分队调查人员估计，为了最终落入水库，汽车必须以大约30度的角度向右转弯。然后它穿过对向车道，撞破铁丝网，继续穿过草地路基，左侧擦过一棵树，然后落入水中。从路边到水库的距离是44米。汽车行驶的路径清晰而直接。警方没有找到任何表明罗伯特失去对车辆控制的迹象。
There were no signs that Robert had slammed the brakes at any time. Experts checked whether there had been a mechanical failure that caused the fatal accident. They found no major faults with the Commodore, but discovered that it had a lot of wear and tear. It had clocked up 387,000 kilometres on its odometer, had second-hand tyres, and the engine was known to cut out on occasion. A mechanic who'd recently serviced the car had noticed that it tended to drift a right while being driven.
没有任何迹象表明罗伯特在任何时候猛踩过刹车。专家们检查了是否是机械故障导致了这起致命事故。“海军准将”没有发现重大故障，但发现它有很多磨损。它的里程表已经行驶了387,000公里，使用的是二手轮胎，并且发动机偶尔会熄火。最近为该车做过保养的机械师注意到，它在行驶时往往会向右偏。
He'd recommended a wheel alignment to correct this, but didn't have the equipment to do so himself. He performed a wheel balancing instead. A police examination found no problems with the car's wheel alignment. The right rear door, next to where Tyler had been seated, was faulty and could only be opened from the inside. When the car was recovered, both of the rear doors were locked, with a child-proof lock also engaged on the faulty one.
他建议做四轮定位来纠正这一点，但他自己没有这方面的设备。相反，他做了车轮动平衡。警方检查发现该车的车轮定位没有问题。靠近泰勒座位的右后门有故障，只能从内部打开。当汽车被捞起时，两个后门都是锁着的，故障的那个门还启用了儿童安全锁。
Disturbed by the turn that the case was taking, Sergeant Smith began compiling two lists. One, he titled, he did it. Under that, he wrote down a number of incriminating facts, such as Robert's demeanour, his inconsistent story, the way the scene didn't match what he'd described, and Robert's insistence above all else on being driven to his ex-wife so he could be the one to tell her that their sons had died. The other list was labelled, he didn't do it. The only thing Sergeant Smith could think to write under that one was, who could be
对案件的发展方向感到不安的史密斯警长开始整理两份清单。一份他标题为“他干的”。在下面，他写下了许多 incriminating 事实，例如罗伯特的态度、他前后矛盾的说法、现场与他描述不符的地方，以及罗伯特最坚持要求被送到前妻那里，以便由他来告诉她他们的儿子们已经死了。另一份清单标为“不是他干的”。史密斯警长唯一能想到写在下面的只有：“谁能这么
this evil? Victoria Police's Homicide Squad officially took control of the investigation, with Detective Senior Sergeant Gerard Clanchy at the helm. One of their first actions was to conduct a formal interview with Robert Farquhusson, who had been discharged from hospital. Detective Clanchy and Senior Constable Andrew Stamper drove to Robert Street and found journalists and TV crews already gathered there. Winshillsie was close-knit, so news of the tragic incident spread quickly.
邪恶？”维多利亚州警察凶杀案调查组正式接管了调查，由高级侦探杰拉德·克兰奇（Gerard Clanchy）带头。他们的首要行动之一是对已经出院的罗伯特·法库森进行正式讯问。克兰奇侦探和高级警员安德鲁·斯坦珀（Andrew Stamper）驱车前往罗伯特街，发现记者和电视摄制组已经在那里聚集。温切尔西是个紧密相连的社区，所以这起悲惨事件的消息迅速传开。
But its impact was far greater than the small touristy town. The entire state was in mourning for the three young boys. Clanchy and Stamper approached the house that Robert shared with his father, Don. It was a cramped, cold place that Cindy had nicknamed the Morgue. Prior to Robert moving in almost a year earlier, his father had lived there alone since Robert's mother died of lung cancer in 2002. Her loss had been devastating to Robert. He had been his mother's favorite child.
但它的影响远远超出了这个旅游小镇。整个州都在为三个年幼的男孩哀悼。克兰奇和斯坦珀走近罗伯特与他父亲唐（Don）合住的房子。这是一个狭窄阴冷的地方，辛迪给它起名叫“停尸房”。在罗伯特搬进来近一年前，他的母亲于2002年因肺癌去世后，他的父亲就一直独自住在那里。失去母亲对罗伯特来说是毁灭性的打击。他是母亲最疼爱的孩子。
The two officers knocked on the front door. Don answered and ushered them inside to where Robert was sitting. They informed Robert that they needed him to accompany them to police headquarters in Melbourne for a recorded interview. He agreed. The three men piled into the police car for the two-hour journey. Constable Stamper sat in the back seat with Robert and chatted with him throughout the drive while Detective Clanchy drove.
两名警官敲了敲前门。唐开门把他们迎了进去，来到罗伯特坐着的地方。他们通知罗伯特，需要他陪同前往墨尔本的警察总部接受录音讯问。他同意了。三个男人挤进警车，开始了两个小时的旅程。斯坦珀警员和罗伯特坐在后座上，一路上和他聊天，克兰奇侦探负责开车。
Unbeknownst to Robert, Stamper was wearing a wire. After some friendly back-and-forth, the Constable asked Robert what he thought might have happened the night that his sons died. Robert said he struggled to remember all of the details but was adamant it had been an accident. He'd done all he could to save his boys. He maintained his version of events when the formal interview commenced at the police headquarters. Once again, he detailed how he had a coughing fit and awoke to find his car in the dam.
罗伯特不知道的是，斯坦珀身上带着窃听器。在一番友好的寒暄后，警员问罗伯特，他觉得他儿子们去世的那天晚上可能发生了什么。罗伯特说，他很难记起所有的细节，但坚称那是一场意外。他已经尽其所能去救他的孩子了。当正式审讯在警察总部开始时，他坚持了自己的一贯说法。他再次详细讲述了自己是如何一阵咳嗽，醒来时发现自己的车在水库里。
He had no idea how its headlights and ignition came to be turned off. When asked why he'd insisted on being driven to Cindy's house after the accident instead of seeking help, Robert replied, I don't know, I can't answer that. Although Jay, Tyler and Bailey were found unrestrained, the officers had confirmed this was not Robert's doing. The boys had somehow managed to free themselves. They asked why he hadn't managed to unbuckle any of their seatbelts.
他完全不知道车的前灯和点火开关是怎么关掉的。当被问及事故发生后为什么坚持让人开车送他去辛迪家而不是寻求帮助时，罗伯特回答说：“我不知道，我回答不了这个问题。”尽管杰伊、泰勒和贝利被发现时身上没有系安全带，但警官们已经证实这不是罗伯特干的。这几个男孩不知怎么设法解开了安全带。他们质问他为什么没能解开他们中任何一个人的安全带。
Robert's tone became indignant. He responded, I've got two arms, two legs, I can't save three. His lower lip trembled but to detectives, it appeared that he was only pretending to look distressed. Despite his recent marriage breakdown, Robert said he bore his ex-wife no ill will. Their relationship had begun to falter a few years earlier. Cindy had realised she'd never truly been in love with Robert and felt he was more of a friend.
罗伯特的语气变得气愤起来。他回答说：“我有两只胳膊两条腿，我救不了三个。”他的下唇微微颤抖，但在侦探们看来，他似乎只是在装出痛苦的样子。尽管最近婚姻破裂，但罗伯特说他对前妻没有任何恶意。他们的关系几年前就开始走下坡路了。辛迪意识到她从来没有真正爱过罗伯特，觉得他更像是个朋友。
Robert also struggled with depression following his mother's cancer diagnosis and resisted Cindy's requests to seek help. By the time he finally did so in October 2004, Cindy told him she wanted a divorce. Cindy told Robert not to worry about paying child support and to focus on saving money for his own home instead. But Robert insisted, pointing out that it would be illegal for him not to provide financially for his kids. He also continued paying off the mortgage on the family home without resistance.
在母亲被诊断出癌症后，罗伯特也一直在与抑郁症作斗争，并拒绝了辛迪寻求帮助的要求。直到2004年10月他终于这么做时，辛迪告诉他她想离婚。辛迪告诉罗伯特不用担心支付孩子的抚养费，把精力放在攒钱买自己的房子上就行。但罗伯特坚持要付，并指出在经济上不抚养孩子是违法的。他还毫不抗拒地继续偿还家庭住房的抵押贷款。
The only bone of contention was the division of the couple's two cars. They owned two Holden Commodores. One was a 1989 white model with a lot of wear and tear, while the other was a 2002 silver VX. Cindy insisted on having the newer car as she would be the parent responsible for driving the children around the most. Robert agreed, but was annoyed about being stuck with, quote, the shit car, while Cindy got the good one.
唯一争执不下的是两人两辆车的分配问题。他们拥有两辆霍顿海军准将汽车。一辆是1989年的白色旧款，磨损严重；另一辆是2002年的银色VX款。辛迪坚持要那辆较新的车，因为她将是负责开车带孩子最多的家长。罗伯特同意了，但对只能开那辆“破车”而辛迪能开好车感到恼火。
He told the two officers that he wasn't jealous that Cindy had already seemingly moved on with Steven Miles. She'd gone out of her way to make sure he stayed involved in the boys' lives. It was adamant that Cindy and her family didn't blame him for the accident and had already visited him to reassure him of that. When Clanchy asked Robert point blank if he'd deliberately driven into the dam, Robert replied, No, I did not. His eyes slid away from the detectives.
他告诉两名警官，他并不嫉妒辛迪似乎已经和史蒂芬·迈尔斯开始新的生活。她想方设法确保他参与到男孩们的生活中。她坚信辛迪和她的家人并没有因为这场事故而责怪他，并且已经拜访过他以向他保证这一点。当克兰奇开门见山地问罗伯特他是否是故意把车开进水库的时，罗伯特回答说：“不，我没有。”他的目光从侦探们身上移开了。
It demanded that police have him take a polygraph test to prove he wasn't lying. Detectives agreed, and he subsequently sat for a test at Geelong police station. It failed to provide a clear result. When Cindy found out that her ex-husband had been questioned by homicide detectives, she was devastated. She was certain that her son's deaths had been a tragic accident. The thought that Robert was under suspicion exacerbated her grief and anguish. Autopsies confirmed that all three boys had drowned.
警方要求他进行测谎测试以证明他没有说谎。侦探们同意了，随后他在吉朗警察局参加了测试。测试未能提供明确的结果。当辛迪得知她的前夫遭到凶杀案侦探的盘问时，她崩溃了。她确信她儿子的死是一场悲惨的事故。罗伯特遭到怀疑的想法加剧了她的悲伤和痛苦。尸检证实这三个男孩都溺水身亡。
There was nothing in their systems that indicated they had been drugged before their deaths. Jay had several abrasions on the left side of his forehead and face, which had likely come from his head hitting the windscreen. The boys had no other notable injuries. In the days after the accident, three small white crosses were erected along the highway near the dam. Locals visited to leave flowers, cards and toys. Cindy and Robert began making funeral plans.
他们体内没有任何迹象表明他们在死前被下药。杰伊的前额和脸部左侧有多处擦伤，这很可能是他的头部撞到挡风玻璃造成的。这些男孩没有其他明显的伤情。事故发生后的几天里，高速公路水库旁竖起了三个白色小十字架。当地人纷纷前来献上鲜花、卡片和玩具。辛迪和罗伯特开始筹划葬礼。
Cindy purchased the burial vault for Jay, Tyler and Bailey at Winchelsea Cemetery. She also bought a plot alongside her for herself so she could be laid to rest with her boys when she passed. Ten days later, Robert followed suit by purchasing an adjoining grave. On September 14, hundreds of Winchelsea residents gathered at St John the Baptist Catholic Church, including children from the local primary school and Jay's scout group. Big chairs and a giant screen had been set up outside to accommodate the mourners who wouldn't fit inside the small bluestone chapel.
辛迪在温切尔西公墓为杰伊、泰勒和贝利买下了墓穴。她还为自己买下了旁边的一块墓地，以便在她去世后能和她的孩子们葬在一起。十天后，罗伯特也效仿买下了相邻的墓地。9月14日，数百名温切尔西居民聚集在圣约翰浸信会天主教堂，其中包括当地小学的孩子和杰伊的童子军团成员。外面摆好了大椅子和一个巨型屏幕，以容纳无法挤进小型蓝石小教堂的哀悼者。
At the front of the church were three small caskets, each of which had been personalized with a memento. Jay's had a football pendant he'd recently been awarded, Tyler's had an Essendon Football Club bear and Bailey's had a toy chainsaw and a Bob the Builder hat. Inside, each of the boys wore a locket that Robert had purchased specially and filled with a photo of their parents. At the end of the service, the boys' favorite song, Holdly Grail by Hunters and Collectors was played for the congregation as pallbearers carried their caskets from the church.
教堂前方摆放着三个小棺材，每一个都用一件纪念品做了个性化装饰。杰伊的棺材上有一个他最近获得的足球吊坠，泰勒的棺材上有一只埃森登足球俱乐部的小熊，贝利则有一个玩具链锯和一个巴布工程师帽。在里面，每个男孩都戴着一个挂坠，这是罗伯特特意买的，里面装有他们父母的照片。仪式结束时，抬棺人将男孩们的棺材抬出教堂，会众们聆听了男孩们最喜欢的歌曲——猎人与收藏家乐队的《圣杯》。
Cindy wailed as her boys were taken to the waiting hearse. Press photographers captured pictures of her clutching Robert supportively, whose face was also contorted with grief as they walked outside into the spring sunshine. Meanwhile, the homicides squad continued their investigation. They spoke to the owner of the property where the dam was located. He said that over the past eight years, seven vehicles had crashed through his fence from the highway. Robert Farquasen's was the only one that had ended up in the dam.
当男孩们的遗体被抬上等候的灵车时，辛迪放声痛哭。新闻摄影记者拍下了她紧紧搂住罗伯特以示支持的照片，当他们走到外面沐浴在春日的阳光下时，罗伯特的脸上也因悲伤而扭曲。与此同时，凶杀案调查组仍在继续他们的调查。他们与水库所在物业的业主进行了交谈。他说，在过去的八年里，有七辆车从高速公路冲破他的栅栏。罗伯特·法夸尔森的车是唯一一辆最终冲进水库的车。
Acting Sergeant Glenn Urquhart of the Major Collision Investigation Unit carried out a series of tests. He used a 1990 Holden Commodore with a video camera set up inside to film the entire experiment. Tire prints left by Robert's car indicated he'd been travelling at a speed of around 60km per hour. Urquhart set off down the same stretch of highway, cruising along at 64km. When he took his hands off the wheel, it didn't veer right as Robert Farquasen's car had, but instead, began to drift to the left.
重大交通事故调查组的代理警长格伦·厄克特进行了一系列测试。他使用了一辆1990款霍顿海军准将汽车，车内架设了摄像机来拍摄整个实验过程。罗伯特车轮留下的轮胎印表明他的车速约为每小时60公里。厄克特开着车驶上同一段高速公路，以64公里的时速行驶。当他把手从方向盘上移开时，车并没有像罗伯特·法夸尔森的车那样向右偏驶，而是开始向左偏离。
Urquhart tried again multiple times, testing out the faster speeds of 82 and 101km as well as the much slower one of 10km. In those three instances, the car continued travelling directly ahead in a neat straight line. Although Robert's mechanic said his car was inclined to veer right, Urquhart knew there was a big difference between a slow drift across lanes and the sharp turn the Commodore had taken. Using a specialised computer software program, Urquhart reconstructed the car's path.
厄克特多次尝试，测试了82公里和101公里较快的速度，以及10公里较慢的速度。在这三种情况下，汽车都沿着一条整齐的直线继续直行。尽管罗伯特的机械师说他的车有向右偏的倾向，但厄克特知道，车道间的缓慢偏离与海军准将车急转弯之间有着巨大的区别。厄克特使用专用的计算机软件程序重构了汽车的行驶轨迹。
He found that Robert must have turned his steering wheel at a 220 degree angle in order for the car to take the dramatic trajectory it had travelled. After turning right off the highway, Robert would have had to drive straight towards the dam, then veer right again to avoid hitting a nearby tree. It stood to reason that none of these actions could have been taken if he was unconscious at the time. Police also carried out experiments at a similar dam in the regional city of Ballarat to see how long it would take a vehicle to sink.
他发现罗伯特必然将方向盘转动了220度，汽车才能开出它所行驶的那种戏剧性的轨迹。从高速公路右转后，罗伯特必须径直朝水库开去，然后再次右转以避开附近的一棵树。显而易见，如果他当时失去了知觉，这些动作是绝对无法完成的。警方还在区域城市巴拉arat的一个类似水库进行了实验，以观察车辆下沉需要多长时间。
They kept the location a secret to prevent members of the press turning up. After plunging into the water, the car bobbed on the surface, floating harmlessly. Only when a police diver opened the driver's side door did it start to sink. Within 15 seconds, it had reached the bottom. This various medical tests had revealed nothing that could account for a coughing fit so extreme that it resulted in him losing consciousness. Detectives consulted doctors who concluded that Farquharson's version of events were highly unlikely at best.
他们对地点保密，以防止记者赶到。冲进水水中后，汽车在水面上上下浮动，无害地漂浮着。直到一名警方潜水员打开了驾驶员侧的车门，它才开始下沉。在15秒内，它就沉到了底部。各种医学测试没有发现任何可以解释如此极端以至于导致他失去知觉的咳嗽发作的原因。侦探们咨询了医生，他们得出结论，法夸尔森对事件的说法充其量也极不可能发生。
Several days after police began looking into the case, officers in Geelong received a phone call from a man named Colin who had a tip for them. Colin was a former policeman who now worked at a local bus company. He was worried. One of his drivers was a close friend of Robert Farquharson's and had appeared increasingly distressed in the days following the accident in Winshawsey. He suggested detectives speak to the driver, whose name was Greg. Officers brought Greg into the station.
警方开始调查此案几天后，吉朗的警官接到了一名叫科林的男子的电话，他掌握了一条线索。科林是一名曾在当地一家公交公司工作的退休警察。他很担心。他的一名司机是罗伯特·法夸尔森的密友，在温肖西事故发生后的几天里，他显得越来越痛苦。他建议侦探们跟这位名叫格雷克的司机谈谈。警官们把格雷克带到了警察局。
He seemed relieved when he was asked to share what he knew. Two months prior to the accident, Greg had driven his children to Winshawsey's fish and chip shop at six o'clock on a Friday evening. While his kids went inside to collect the family's order, Greg waited out the front in his car. Robert Farquharson was also in the shop with his own children, but he came outside for a chat when he spotted Greg's car. Greg noticed that Robert seemed down in the dumps.
当被要求分享他所知道的情况时，他似乎松了一口气。事故发生前两个月的一个周五晚上六点，格雷克开车带着孩子们去温肖西的炸鱼薯条店。当他的孩子们进屋去取家庭订单时，格雷克把车停在前面等候。罗伯特·法夸尔森也和自己的孩子在店里，但他看到格雷克的车后就出来聊天了。格雷克注意到罗伯特似乎情绪低落。
As the two were talking, Cindy Gambino also pulled up in her silver Commodore. She smiled and said hello to the two men before entering the shop where her two sons were. Robert ignored her. Greg reprimanded Robert for being rude, but Robert became angry, snapping, I've got nothing. Nobody does that to me and gets away with it. It's all her fault. He was furious about Cindy driving the family's new car that he'd paid $30,000 for while he was stuck with the fucking shit one.
正当两人交谈时，辛迪·甘比诺也开着她的银色海军准将车停了下来。她微笑着跟两人打了个招呼，然后走进店里找她的两个儿子。罗伯特没有理她。格雷克斥责罗伯特没礼貌，但罗伯特生起气来，冲口而出：“我什么都没有。没人敢这么对我还能逍遥法外。这全都是她的错。”他对辛迪开着他花3万美元买的家庭新车而自己却只能开那辆该死的破车感到愤怒。
Even worse, he sometimes saw Cindy's new boyfriend, Stephen, driving the car. He was enraged at the thought that Stephen might move into the home he and Cindy had built together while Robert was still paying off its mortgage. Finally, he said, she's going to pay big time for this. I'm going to take away the most important thing to her. As he said this, Robert nodded his head towards the fish and chip shop where his ex-wife and children were still inside. When Greg asked what he meant by the statement, Robert mumbled something about having had
更糟糕的是，他有时会看到辛迪的新男友史蒂芬开这辆车。一想到史蒂芬可能会搬进他和辛迪一起建造的房子里，而罗伯特还在还房贷，他就怒火中烧。最后，他说：“她这次要付出沉重的代价。我要夺走对她来说最重要东西。”说这话时，罗伯特朝着前妻和孩子们还在里面的炸鱼薯条店点了点头。当格雷克问他这话是什么意思时，罗伯特含糊不清地嘟囔着说他做了一个
a dream where he drove into a dam. He survived the accident, but all of his sons died. Greg had been horrified by Robert's comments, but before he could inquire further, their conversation was interrupted by Greg's kids returning. He and his children headed home, where Greg immediately told his wife about Robert's disturbing remarks. His wife later said she had no memory of this conversation. Although Greg was troubled, he didn't really think anything would come of Robert's threats.
梦，梦见自己把车开进了一个水库。他在事故中幸存下来，但他的所有儿子都死了。格雷克被罗伯特的话吓坏了，但还没等他进一步追问，格雷克的孩子回来了，打断了他们的谈话。他和孩子们回了家，格雷克立刻把罗伯特令人不安的言论告诉了妻子。他的妻子后来表示她不记得有这番对话了。尽管格雷克感到不安，但他并不认为罗伯特的威胁会变成现实。
Robert was known to whinge and complain, and Greg suspected he was angry, but would never actually act out his rage. Two months later, when he heard that Robert had driven his three sons into a dam and was the only one to survive, Greg became distraught. He couldn't stop thinking about their conversation. He felt sick with guilt that he hadn't done anything about it. Greg had nightmares about the accident and cried unexpectedly. His distress was obvious to everyone around him and led to Colin calling the police.
罗伯特一向爱发牢骚和抱怨，格雷克怀疑他是在生气，但绝不会真的把怒火付诸行动。两个月后，当他听说罗伯特把三个儿子开车载进水库并且是唯一的幸存者时，格雷克崩溃了。他脑海里挥之不去地想着他们的对话。他为自己没有采取任何行动而感到内疚得生病。格雷克做着关于事故的噩梦，并不由自主地哭泣。他身边的所有人都能看出他的痛苦，这导致科林报了警。
After providing detectives with two statements, Greg agreed to help them by reaching out to Robert. He would ask his friend about the accident, all the while recording the conversation by wearing a wire. Greg had been too upset to attend the Farquharson Boys' funeral, so he paid a visit to Robert at home the day after they were laid to rest. He apologized for his absence the day prior. That shrugged it off, saying, A lot of people didn't come.
在向侦探们提供了两份证词后，格雷克同意通过联系罗伯特来协助他们。他将向他的朋友询问事故情况，同时身上带着窃听器将谈话录音。格雷克因为太难过而没能参加法夸尔森男孩们的葬礼，于是在他们入土为安的第二天去家里拜访了罗伯特。他为前一天的缺席道歉。罗伯特不以为然地耸耸肩说：“很多人都没来。
I understand that. It's a million times harder for me, so you don't have to say nothing. I know. Greg reminded Robert of their conversation outside the fish and chip shop and added, I hope it's got nothing to do with that. Robert immediately denied having meant anything nefarious by his previous remarks, saying, No, no way. No, no, no, no, no.
我理解。对我来说这要难上一百万倍，所以你什么都不用说。我知道。”格雷克提醒罗伯特他们在炸鱼薯条店外的那番谈话，并补充道：“我希望这跟那件事没关系。”罗伯特立即否认他之前的言论有任何邪恶的意图，说道：“不，绝不可能。不，不，不，不，不。
You know I would never. Greg confided that police had asked to speak with him and he was freaking out at the prospect. Robert encouraged him to tell them what an excellent father he'd been. He urged Greg to avoid mentioning the fish and chip shop conversation altogether, lest investigators get the wrong idea. Despite Greg's repeated attempts to draw out a confession, Robert insisted the crash had been nothing more than a tragic accident, saying, No way I would do anything like that. That has never, ever entered my mind.
你知道我绝不会的。”格雷克吐露说警察要求跟他谈谈，他对此前景感到恐慌。罗伯特鼓励他告诉警察他是一个多么优秀的父亲。他敦促格雷克完全不要提及炸鱼薯条店的那番谈话，以免调查人员产生错误的看法。尽管格雷克多次试图套出他的供词，但罗伯特坚称坠车只是一场悲惨的事故，并说道：“我绝不可能做出那样的事。我脑子里从来、从来没有过这种想法。”
When police later listened to the recording, they were encouraged to hear that Robert had acknowledged the fish and chip shop conversation. Maybe if pressed again, he might make a full admission. They had Greg repeat the exercise one month later, on October 13. This time, Greg asked Robert what he'd meant about having a dream where he drove into a dam. Robert denied making such a comment, stating, I never, never said that. You're getting it all wrong, all twisted.
当警方后来听取录音时，听到罗伯特承认了炸鱼薯条店的谈话，他们备受鼓舞。也许如果再次逼问，他可能会彻底招认。他们让格雷克在一个月后的10月13日重复这一行动。这一次，格雷克问罗伯特关于梦见自己开车冲进水库的事到底是什么意思。罗伯特否认发表过这样的言论，并声称：“我从来、从来没说过这话。你全弄错了，全扭曲了。
I meant, one day Cindy's going to wake up that I'm not as weak as Piss as what she thought. I'm going to accomplish something. He was upset that his friend would suggest such a thing. He admitted he'd initially been angry at Cindy following their split, but they'd been on good terms by the time he ran into Greg at the fish and chip shop. He also claimed that he'd blacked out from coughing about a week before the accident. On September 1, Robert had told a friend that he'd had a coughing fit while driving and briefly passed out behind the wheel.
我的意思是，总有一天辛迪会醒悟过来，发现我并非像她想象的那样软弱无能。我要干出一番成就来。”他对朋友会提出这种事感到很不高兴。他承认自己在分手后最初对辛迪很生气，但在炸鱼薯条店偶遇格雷克时，他们的关系已经很融洽了。他还声称，在事故发生前大约一周，他曾因为咳嗽而短暂晕厥。9月1日，罗伯特曾告诉一位朋友，他在开车时一阵咳嗽，并在方向盘后面短暂昏迷了过去。
When he woke, he realised his car had continued travelling an additional 20 metres down the road. Detectives were surprised by this sudden mention of another blackout. They asked Greg to keep reflecting on the fish and chip shop conversation and to write down anything else that he remembered. Meanwhile, they kept investigating. They tapped Robert's phone, but captured nothing incriminating. Throughout November, Greg couldn't stop thinking about the conversation.
当他醒来时，他意识到自己的车在路上又多行驶了20米。侦探们对突然提及的另一次昏迷感到意外。他们让格雷克继续回想炸鱼薯条店的那番谈话，并写下他记起的任何其他事情。与此同时，他们继续调查。他们监听了罗伯特的电话，但没有搜集到任何 incriminating（定罪）的证据。整个11月，格雷克满脑子都是那番谈话。
More details were coming back to him. As these memories returned, he typed notes on his computer, keeping a written record of each new recollection. The more he wrote, the more he recalled. Greg remembered that when he asked Robert what he meant by saying he'd take the most important thing away from Cindy, Robert looked directly at him and said, kill them. Greg called his bluff, saying, bullshit, that's your own flesh and blood, Robbie. Robert retorted, so I hate them.
更多的细节浮现在他的脑海中。随着这些记忆的恢复，他在电脑上打字做笔记，将每一个新的回忆以书面形式记录下来。他写得越多，回想起的就越多。格雷克记起，当他问罗伯特说要夺走对辛迪来说最重要东西是什么意思时，罗伯特直盯着他说：“杀了他们。”格雷克不相信他的鬼话，说道：“少废话，那是你的亲生骨肉，罗比。”罗伯特反驳道：“所以我恨他们。”
Then he detailed how he would have an accident in a dam and it would take place on Father's Day. That way, everyone would remember it and he would be the one with the boys during their final moments. On every Father's Day that followed, Cindy would be tormented by the memory of how her sons died. Greg forwarded his typed document to Detective Jared Clanchy and a warrant was issued for Robert's arrest.
然后他详细叙述了他是如何在水库制造一场事故的，而且这会发生在父亲节那天。这样一来，每个人都会记住它，而在他们生命中的最后时刻陪伴在男孩们身边的将是他。在随后的每一个父亲节，辛迪都会被儿子们是如何死去的记忆折磨。格雷克将他打印好的文档转发给侦探杰瑞德·克兰奇，随后警方发出了对罗伯特的逮捕令。
On December 14, 2005, Robert voluntarily surrendered himself to the Geelong police station accompanied by his lawyer. He was charged with three counts of murder and remanded to custody. He was granted bail two weeks later after his lawyer successfully argued that Robert was a low flight risk and had tremendous support throughout his community. Cindy Gambino was devastated to learn her ex-husband was charged with murdering their three sons. Robert had been a proud and dedicated father who encouraged his children's hobbies and
2005年12月14日，罗伯特在律师的陪同下向吉朗警察局自首。他被控三项谋杀罪并被还押候审。两周后，在律师成功辩称罗伯特潜逃风险低且在社区拥有巨大支持后，他获得了保释。得知前夫被控谋杀他们的三个儿子，辛迪·甘比诺悲痛欲绝。罗伯特曾是一个骄傲而敬业的父亲，他鼓励孩子们的爱好，
took them out for fun activities like swimming and bike riding. She couldn't believe he'd be capable of deliberately harming them, nor would he ever want to. She was also aware that Robert was prone to suffer from bad coughs each winter. To her, his version of events seemed entirely plausible. Much of the Winchelsea community shared Cindy's support of Robert, with one of her relatives telling the Herald Sun newspaper, nobody believes it. But other members of the public had their doubts. They thought Robert's story about a coughing fit sounded utterly absurd.
带他们出去进行游泳和骑自行车等有趣的活动。她不相信他会蓄意伤害他们，也绝不会有这种想法。她也知道罗伯特每年冬天都容易患上严重的咳嗽。对她来说，他的说法似乎完全合情合理。温切尔西社区的很多人都和辛迪一样支持罗伯特，她的一位亲属告诉《先驱太阳报》：“没人相信这是真的。”但也有其他公众成员心存疑虑。他们认为罗伯特关于咳嗽发作的说法听起来荒谬绝伦。
Since the deaths of her sons, Cindy Gambino had become fixated with the colour purple. It was a colour she'd always loved, and the fact that new age types believed it was associated with healing made it even more appealing. When Robert's trial began in Victoria's Supreme Court on August 21, 2007, Cindy made sure she was wearing purple as she attended in support of her ex-husband. When it was time for her to take the stand, she sobbed as she described how Robert had appeared at her home, soaking wet and babbling that their children had drowned. Following the tragedy, Cindy had a number of conversations with Robert in which she
自从儿子们去世后，辛迪·甘比诺就对紫色情有独钟。这是她一直很喜欢的颜色，而新时代信仰者认为它与治愈有关，这使得它更具吸引力。2007年8月21日，当罗伯特的审判在维多利亚州最高法院开始时，辛迪特意穿着一身紫色出席，以支持她的前夫。轮到她出庭作证时，她抽泣着描述了罗伯特是如何浑身湿透、语无伦次地出现在她家说他们的孩子溺水身亡的。悲剧发生后，辛迪与罗伯特有过多次交谈，她在交谈中
offered support and comfort. Even though she didn't hold him responsible, she knew how guilty he must have felt. She was adamant that there was no way he could have killed their children on purpose. After Cindy finished testifying, she left the courtroom. She could be heard wailing outside. Early on in the trial, the jury was driven from Melbourne out to the dam in Winchelsea so they could survey the site for themselves. The three white crosses symbolizing the young lives lost there still stood by the highway.
给予了他支持和安慰。尽管她不认为他应该承担责任，但她知道他的内心一定感到多么愧疚。她坚信他绝不可能故意杀死他们的孩子。辛迪作证结束后，离开了法庭。人们能听到她在外面放声大哭。审判刚开始时，陪审团被从墨尔本驱车送往温切尔西的水库，以便他们亲自实地考察现场。标志着那里消逝的年轻生命的三个白色十字架依然矗立在公路旁。
Acting Sergeant Glenn Urquhart of the Major Collision Investigation Unit told the jury about his work on the case and how Robert Farquherson had to drive deliberately and turn his steering wheel 220 degrees to end up in the dam. A defence expert dismissed Urquhart's evidence, arguing that there should have been sideways skid marks on the road if Robert had driven as Urquhart described. He believed the car's reported tendency to drift right and the slight right-leaning slope of the road would have been enough to accidentally drive into the dam. The prosecution's star witness was Robert's friend, Greg.
重大交通事故调查组代理警长格伦·厄克特向陪审团讲述了他对该案的研究工作，以及罗伯特·法夸尔森如何必须蓄意开车并将方向盘转动220度才会冲进水库。一名辩护专家驳斥了厄克特的证据，辩称如果像厄克特所说的那样驾驶，路上应该会留下侧向的刹车痕迹。他认为汽车据称向右偏驶的倾向以及道路轻微向右倾斜的坡度，已经足以导致汽车意外开进水库。控方的明星证人是罗伯特的朋友格雷克。
As the covert recordings he'd made of his chats with Robert were played to the court, Robert repeatedly shook his head. The defence found it suspicious that the more Greg spoke to police, the more incriminating and detailed his recollections had become. They suggested Greg was so disturbed by the tragedy that he couldn't distinguish between his nightmares and reality. But Greg firmly defended his evidence. Coming forward had been incredibly painful, but he'd done it because he felt obligated
当他与罗伯特谈话的秘密录音在法庭上播放时，罗伯特不停地摇头。辩方发现可疑的是，格雷克跟警方谈得越多，他记起的内容就越具 incriminating（入罪性）且越详细。他们暗示格雷克被这场悲剧折磨得无法分清噩梦与现实。但格雷克坚定地为自己的证据辩护。站出来作证极其痛苦，但他这么做是因为他觉得自己有义务
to do so. Robert's legal team opted against calling him to the stand to testify in his own defence. Instead, their case hinged on expert testimony regarding Robert's claim that he'd blacked out following a coughing fit. Dr Christopher Steinfett, a thoracic specialist, informed the court that he thought Robert exhibited some classic symptoms of a cough syncope. Although this was a highly rare condition usually seen in people with chronic lung disease, Dr Steinfett said it could be triggered by a bout of the flu.
这样做。罗伯特的法律团队选择不传唤他出庭为自己辩护。相反，他们的辩护核心在于关于罗伯特声称咳嗽发作后昏迷的专家证言。胸科专家克里斯托弗·斯坦费特博士告诉法庭，他认为罗伯特表现出了一些咳嗽性晕厥的典型症状。尽管这是一种罕见的疾病，通常见于慢性肺病患者，但斯坦费特博士表示，它可能会由一次流感发作触发。
It was a condition he was familiar with. Roughly 15 patients who'd attended his private practice over the past decade had reported instances of a cough syncope. More recently, a GP had informed him of another case where a man who was driving his children to a football game suffered a coughing fit and ran his car off the road. Dr Steinfett examined Robert Farquhusson on a number of occasions following the damn accident. Although Robert didn't suffer from lung disease, he was an overweight smoker with sleep apnea,
这是他熟悉的一种病情。在过去十年中，他的私人诊所看过的约15名患者曾报告过咳嗽性晕厥的病例。最近，一位全科医生告诉他另一个病例，一名开车送孩子去踢足球的男子遭遇了咳嗽发作，导致汽车冲出公路。在水库事故发生后，斯坦费特博士曾多次为罗伯特·法夸尔森做检查。尽管罗伯特没有患肺病，但他是一个超重的吸烟者，患有睡眠呼吸暂停，
which could make him more prone to coughing bouts. He'd also been witnessed coughing severely in the past. But Matthew Norton, a specialist in sleep and respiratory medicine who testified for the prosecution, believed it was highly unlikely Robert had suffered from a cough syncope. Anything he'd ever seen or read about the disorder in medical literature pointed to individuals with healthy heart, lung, and neurological functions experiencing it. He thought it was even less likely that Robert would have passed out as the car was warm due to its heater being on.
这可能使他更容易发生咳嗽。过去也曾有人目击他剧烈咳嗽。但为控方出庭作证的睡眠与呼吸医学专家马修·诺顿认为，罗伯特极不可能患有咳嗽性晕厥。他所看过或读过的关于该疾病的所有医学文献都指出，患此病的都是心脏、肺部和神经功能健康的个人。他认为，由于车内开着暖气导致车内温暖，罗伯特因此晕厥的可能性甚至更小。
Although Robert had claimed he'd blacked out on at least one other occasion due to coughing, this couldn't be confirmed by any eyewitnesses or medical evidence. To demonstrate that Robert had never had any desire to harm his family, the defence also called his counsellor to the stand. Following his split with Cindy, Robert finally started receiving treatment for depression that he'd experienced since his mother's illness and death several years earlier. He'd had about six appointments with a counsellor named Peter Popko, telling him how upset he was over the breakdown of his family.
尽管罗伯特声称他至少还有一次因为咳嗽而晕厥，但这无法得到任何目击者或医疗证据的证实。为了证明罗伯特从未有过伤害家人的愿望，辩护方还传唤了他的心理咨询师出庭。与辛迪分手后，罗伯特终于开始接受治疗，以治疗他几年前因母亲生病和去世而患上的抑郁症。他与一位名叫彼得·波普科的咨询师进行了大约六次预约，向他倾诉自己对家庭破裂有多么沮丧。
Robert never expressed any suicidal ideation, nor did he mention wanting to hurt Cindy or their children. The only person he seemed to want revenge against was Stephen Miles. Robert had detailed a fantasy in which he would provoke Stephen into punching him, then take him to court for assault. This revelation came as no surprise to Stephen. He'd met Cindy and Robert shortly before the couple broke up. Although he and Cindy quickly developed a connection, Stephen had recently gone through
罗伯特从未表达过任何自杀意念，也没有提到想伤害辛迪或他们的孩子。他似乎唯一想报复的人是史蒂芬·迈尔斯。罗伯特曾详细描述过一个幻想：他要激怒史蒂芬，让他给自己一拳，然后以殴打罪将他告上法庭。这个爆料对史蒂芬来说并不意外。他在辛迪和罗伯特分手前不久认识了他们。尽管他和辛迪迅速发展出了一种联系，但史蒂芬最近刚刚经历过
his own messy divorce. He was adamant that he wouldn't become involved with a woman who was still married. Instead, he'd inadvertently become a confidant to Robert. After Robert moved out of his and Cindy's home, he began turning up at Stephen's house almost every night of the week, crying and seeking advice. Stephen made suggestions as to how Robert could improve his situation, but Robert never listened or changed his behaviors. He just complained incessantly.
他自己一团糟的离婚。他坚信自己不会和一个还在婚姻中的女人纠缠在一起。相反，他无意中成了罗伯特的心灵知己。罗伯特搬出他和辛迪的家后，几乎每周的每个晚上都跑到史蒂芬家，痛哭流涕地寻求建议。史蒂芬为罗伯特如何改善现状提出了建议，但罗伯特从不听取，也从不改变自己的行为。他只是不停地抱怨。
After a couple of months, Stephen grew fed up with Robert's constant whinging and told him, You know what? You're an idiot. You don't want your wife back. He said Robert should grow up and act like a father instead of a spoiled little boy. Robert stopped asking for Stephen's advice after that, and Stephen subsequently grew closer to Cindy.
几个月后，史蒂芬对罗伯特不断的牢骚感到厌烦，对他说：“你知道吗？你是个笨蛋。你根本不想让妻子回心转意。”他说罗伯特应该成熟一点，像个父亲一样行事，而不是像个被宠坏的小男孩。从那以后，罗伯特不再向史蒂芬征求意见，史蒂芬随后也跟辛迪走得更近了。
On October 2, the jury retired to consider their verdict. Two days later, it was Jay's 13th birthday. Robert arranged for someone to deliver three red tulips to his son's grave, along with a handwritten note that read, Dear Jay, thinking of you on your birthday, love you, dad. On October 5, the jury finally returned. Robert stood, dressed in a grey shirt and a charcoal-coloured tie and trousers, as the jury foreman announced the first verdict.
10月2日，陪审团休庭以考虑他们的裁决。两天后，是杰伊的13岁生日。罗伯特安排人给儿子的墓地送去了三朵红郁金香，并附上了一张手写便条，上面写着：“亲爱的杰伊，在你生日这天思念你，爱你，爸爸。”10月5日，陪审团终于有了结果。罗伯特穿着灰色衬衫、炭灰色领带和长裤站起身来，随着陪审团长宣布第一项裁决。
Guilty of the murder of Jay Farquhwason. Shocked, Robert dropped to his seat. Cindy cried out in despair. Continuing on, the foreman confirmed that Robert had also been found guilty of murdering Tyler and Bailey Farquhwason. Cindy screamed, Why? Why? Why?
谋杀杰伊·法夸尔森罪名成立。罗伯特震惊得一屁股坐回座位上。辛迪绝望地大哭起来。陪审团长继续证实，罗伯特谋杀泰勒和贝利·法夸尔森的罪名也成立。辛迪尖叫道：“为什么？为什么？为什么？”
Her mother Bev fainted. Both women were escorted to an ambulance and treated for shock. One month later, Robert returned to the Supreme Court for sentencing. He kept his head down as the judge addressed him. You wiped out your entire family in one act. Only two parents remained. You, because you had always intended to save yourself, and their mother, because you intended her to live a life of suffering.
她的母亲贝夫晕倒了。两名女性都被护送上救护车并因休克接受治疗。一个月后，罗伯特回到最高法院听取判决。法官对他说话时，他一直低着头。“你在一场行动中消灭了你的整个家庭。只剩下两个家长。一个是你，因为你自始至终都打算拯救你自己；另一个是他们的孩子母亲，因为你打算让她过上充满痛苦的生活。”
He sentenced Robert to three life sentences. He refused to set a minimum term, excluding the possibility for parole. Outside the court, a statement was read to reporters on Robert's behalf. I received a life sentence on the night my boys died, so I don't care much about what other people think of me. I will appeal the verdict, because I will not have the public believe that Jay, Tyler and Bailey were anything less than the most important part of my life. Robert Farquhwason's legal team intended to fight his conviction on 24 separate grounds,
他判处罗伯特三个终身监禁。他拒绝设定最低刑期，排除了假释的可能性。法庭外，有人代表罗伯特向记者宣读了一份声明。“在我儿子们去世的那天晚上，我已经被判处了终身监禁，所以我不在乎别人怎么看我。我会对裁决提出上诉，因为我绝不让公众相信杰伊、泰勒和贝利在我生命中不是最重要的一部分。”罗伯特·法夸尔森的法律团队原本打算以24个不同的理由对他的定罪提出抗诉，
but their main argument was that the prosecution had withheld vital information. Namely, that their star witness, Greg, was a violent man who testified against his best friend in exchange for having his own criminal charges reduced. Eight months before Robert's trial, Greg had been drinking at a pub with his brother-in-law. The pair entered into a physical altercation with some other patrons, one of whom Greg hit three times in the abdomen. After Greg was charged for the assault, Detective Jared Clanchy wrote him a character reference, explaining that he'd been under immense strain due to acting as a police witness in a high-profile
但他们的主要论点是控方隐瞒了至关重要信息。也就是说，他们的明星证人格雷克是一个暴力男子，他出庭指证最好的朋友是为了换取减轻他自己的刑事指控。在罗伯特受审前八个月，格雷克曾和他的小舅子在酒吧喝酒。两人与其他一些顾客发生肢体冲突，格雷克打了其中一人腹部三拳。在格雷克因袭击罪被起诉后，侦探杰瑞德·克兰奇为他写了一份品行证明书，解释说由于作为高调案件的警方证人，他承受了巨大的压力
case. Several weeks after Robert's sentencing, Greg pleaded guilty to a single charge of recklessly causing injury, was placed on a 12-month good behavior bond, and ordered to pay a $750 fine. Robert's defense hadn't been aware of Greg's brush with the law, so were denied the chance to question his character while he was on the stand. On December 17, 2009, it was confirmed that three judges had overturned Robert's conviction and ordered that a new trial be held. Robert was released on $200,000 bail.
。在罗伯特被判刑几周后，格雷克对一项鲁莽造成伤害的指控认罪，被判处12个月的良好行为保证令，并被责令支付750美元罚款。罗伯特的辩护方并不知道格雷克曾触犯法律，因此被剥夺了在他在证人席上时对其品格提出质疑的机会。2009年12月17日，证实三名法官已推翻罗伯特的定罪并下令进行重审。罗伯特以20万美元保释金获释。
His family and supporters were overjoyed. These two sisters attended his bail hearing wearing badges that read, in rob we trust, and fact before theory. But not everybody was celebrating the decision. One individual who was extremely troubled to hear about Robert's release was a woman named Dawn. It was getting late on Sunday, September 4, 2005, when Dawn drove along the Princess Highway.
他的家人和支持者欣喜若狂。这两位姐妹戴着写有“我们信任罗勃”和“事实重于理论”的徽章参加了他的保释听证会。但并非所有人都为这一决定感到庆祝。有一个人对听到罗伯特获释感到极其不安，那就是名叫多恩的女子。2005年9月4日星期日天色渐晚，多恩开车行驶在公主高速公路上。
By 7pm, she was approaching Winshillsie. The early spring weather had been damp and overcast all day. Clouds still hung in the air, masking the stars and making the evening particularly dark. Dawn switched on her headlights high beams to illuminate the poorly lit roadway. That's when she noticed the vehicle up ahead, a light-colored, older model Holden Commodore. It had seen better days. The speed limit on the highway was 100km per hour.
到了晚上7点，她正在接近温希尔西。早春的天气一整天都是潮湿阴沉的。云层依然悬挂在空中，遮住了星星，使傍晚格外黑暗。多恩打开了大灯远光灯，以照亮照明不良的路面。就在那时，她注意到前方有一辆车，是一辆浅色的旧款霍顿海军准将。它已经破旧不堪。高速公路上的限速是每小时100公里。
Dawn found herself quickly gaining on the car ahead. It was travelling very slowly at around half the speed limit. Its brake lights flashed on and off several times and it kept drifting towards the white line separating the two lanes. Dawn decided to overtake the car as the way the driver was veering dangerously close to the opposite lane made her nervous. She flashed her headlights as a warning of her intentions. She then crossed to the opposite lane and accelerated.
多恩发现自己迅速追上了前方的车。它以大约一半限速的速度非常缓慢地行驶着。它的刹车灯闪烁了数次，并且一直向分隔两条车道的白线漂移。多恩决定超车，因为驾驶员危险地靠近对向车道的偏离方式让她感到紧张。她闪烁大灯作为她意图的警告。然后她切入对向车道并加速。
As she drew level with the car, Dawn glanced over at its driver. He was a clean shaven man in his late 30s with dark hair. She tried to make eye contact with him and raised her hands in a questioning gesture as though to ask what exactly he was doing. Even though the man kept glancing to his right, he refused to look at her. His expression was blank as he repeatedly checked his side mirror. It appeared as though he was looking for something, possibly a particular turn-off. As she passed, Dawn also noticed three young children sitting in a row in the back seat
当她与那辆车并驾齐驱时，多恩瞥了一眼它的驾驶员。那是一个三十多岁、刮得净面、留着黑发的男子。她试图与他进行眼神交流，并举起双手做出一个质疑的手势，仿佛在问他到底在干什么。尽管那男子不断向右瞥，但他拒绝看她。他的表情呆滞，一边反复查看侧后视镜。他似乎在寻找什么，可能是一个特定的路口。超车时，多恩还注意到后座上并排坐着三个小孩，
including a fair-haired boy who looked to be about seven or eight years old. He was sitting directly behind the driver with his face pressed against the window. Once Dawn had passed the Commodore, she returned to the left lane. At this point, the highway was gradually rising over a railway track. Dawn sped up the overpass then glanced back at her rear view mirror. The Commodore was in the distance. Its headlights veered right and disappeared. Dawn assumed the driver had turned down an adjoining road.
其中包括一个看起来七八岁左右的金发男孩。他正坐在驾驶员身后，脸紧贴着窗户。多恩超过海军准将车后，回到了左侧车道。此时，高速公路正缓缓跨越一条铁路。多恩加速驶过立交桥，然后回看后视镜。海军准将车在远处。它的车灯向右一偏便消失了。多恩以为司机已经拐进了一条毗邻的道路。
The following evening, Dawn was in her kitchen preparing dinner while watching the news. Footage was shown of Robert Farquharson's car being winched from the dam and Dawn instantly recognized it. She cried out to her daughter. That's the car, that's the car. Although Dawn was incredibly disturbed by the turn of events, she didn't report what she'd seen. Her family had been under a great deal of strain at the time.
第二天傍晚，多恩在厨房里准备晚饭，同时看着新闻。电视上播放了罗伯特·法夸尔森的车从水库被绞上来的画面，多恩一眼就认了出来。她大喊着叫女儿。“那是那辆车，那是那辆车。”尽管这一连串事件让多恩感到极其不安，但她并没有报告她所看到的情况。当时她的家承受着巨大的压力。
Early in 2005, they'd relocated from New Zealand to Australia. They ran a dairy farm in Warnambool, a near two-hour drive from Winchelsea. When Dawn began experiencing chronic illness later that year, she struggled to keep on top of managing the farm. Then, her father and both of her parents-in-law passed away and her 16-year-old daughter lost a close friend in a tragic road accident. All of this stress meant she wanted to avoid another difficult matter. Consequently, Dawn hadn't followed Robert's trial, but was relieved when she heard that
2005年初，他们从新西兰搬到了澳大利亚。他们在沃南布尔经营着一家奶牛场，距离温希尔西有将近两个小时的车程。当多恩在当年晚些时候开始经历慢性疾病时，她很难兼顾管理农场。接着，她的父亲和岳父母双亲相继去世，她16岁的女儿在一场悲惨的车祸中失去了亲密的朋友。所有的这些压力意味着她想要避开另一件棘手的事情。因此，多恩没有关注罗伯特的审判，但当她听说他被起诉并最终定罪时，她感到如释重负。
he'd been charged and ultimately convicted. When she saw that he had won his appeal, she decided that this time she had to speak with the police. After hearing from Dawn, investigators contacted Cindy Gambino to inform her of this new development. Dawn pronounced to them, Cindy had been grappling with her own concerns for some time. Once Robert was incarcerated, he hadn't called Cindy or responded to any of her letters. She'd asked to be put on his visitors list so she could see him in person, but he wouldn't add her, despite accepting visits from their mutual friends.
当她看到他上诉成功时，她决定这次她必须跟警察谈谈。听到多恩的消息后，调查人员联系了辛迪·甘比诺以告知她这一新进展。多恩向他们陈述了此事。辛迪一段时间以来一直在与自己的担忧做斗争。罗伯特入狱后，没有给辛迪打过电话，也没有回复她的任何信件。她曾要求将自己加入他的访客名单以便亲自去看他，但尽管他接受了他们共同朋友的探视，他还是不肯加她。
Cindy was baffled and angry. Why was Robert refusing to see the one person in the world who could understand his pain? She wondered if perhaps her ex-husband didn't want to look at her because she would be able to tell if he was lying. Stephen Miles listened to her concerns patiently. He believed Robert was guilty from the beginning, but deliberately withheld his opinion from Cindy, sensing her faith in Robert's innocence was a coping mechanism. The thought that her sons might have lost their lives because of Robert's anger at her
辛迪感到困惑又愤怒。为什么罗伯特拒绝见世界上唯一能理解他痛苦的人？她纳闷，也许她的前夫不想看她，是因为她能看出他是否在撒谎。史蒂芬·迈尔斯耐心倾听了她的担忧。他从一开始就认为罗伯特有罪，但故意对辛迪隐瞒了自己的意见，因为他感觉得到辛迪对罗伯特清白的信念是一种应对机制。一想到她的儿子们可能因为罗伯特对她的愤怒而失去了生命
was too painful to contemplate. Cindy kept turning over the events in her mind. Her marriage had never been a happy one. In fact, she'd even doubted whether she should be with Robert on their wedding day. By then, they already had two sons, and Robert had proved he wasn't the supportive partner Cindy initially thought he would be. He could be childish, throwing tantrums when household appliances didn't work and leaving much of the parenting to her.
简直无法想象。辛迪一直在脑海里反复回想那些事情。她的婚姻从来都不幸福。事实上，在结婚那天，她甚至怀疑自己是否应该和罗伯特在一起。当时他们已经有了两个儿子，罗伯特证明了他并不是辛迪最初认为的那样一个会体谅人的伴侣。他有时像个孩子，家电坏了会大发脾气，把大部分育儿工作都留给了她。
When the boys were babies, he'd refuse to change their nappies or take turns in feeding them. Cindy had to manage all the day-to-day running of their household, paying bills, preparing meals, and performing basic repairs. She complained to one friend that the relationship was a mortgage, not a marriage. As well as having depression, Robert was diagnosed with avoidant personality disorder, which made him insecure, socially awkward, and hypersensitive to perceived slights. But he had been reliable in one sense – he'd always managed to hold down a steady job.
当男孩们还是婴儿时，他拒绝换尿布或轮流喂奶。辛迪不得不处理家里所有的日常事务，付账单、做饭以及进行基础维修。她向一位朋友抱怨说，这段关系是一笔房贷，而不是婚姻。除了患有抑郁症，罗伯特还被诊断出患有人格回避障碍，这使他缺乏安全感、社交笨拙，并且对感知到的冷落高度敏感。但他在一个方面一直是可靠的——他总能保住一份稳定的工作。
The one exception was when he decided to purchase a lawn mowing franchise and the business failed miserably, leaving him $40,000 in debt. Robert's behavior with their children had often unsettled Cindy. He never smacked them as a form of discipline, but he'd once told her that was because he was scared he'd go overboard if he did. He relentlessly teased the two eldest boys, pushing their buttons until they would start crying or stomp out of the room. It always seemed more like bullying than good-natured roughhousing.
唯一的例外是，当他决定购买一家割草特许经营权时，生意一败涂地，给他留下了4万美元的债务。罗伯特对待孩子们的行为常常让辛迪感到不安。他从不打他们作为惩罚，但他曾告诉她，那是他害怕自己如果动手会下手太重。他无休止地取笑两个大儿子，不断挑衅他们，直到他们哭泣或跺脚离开房间。这看起来总是更像霸凌，而不是善意的打闹。
He'd also been cruel towards her, calling her fat mama, grabbing at her body while she was cooking or cleaning and sulking when she wasn't in the mood for sex. By October 2004, Cindy had had enough. She'd never been in love with Robert, and she told him she wanted a divorce. After they separated, Robert stalked Cindy, driving past her house at all hours of the day. He became fixated with her new relationship and was furious at the thought of another man becoming a father figure to his sons.
他对她也很残酷，叫她胖妈妈，在她做饭或打扫卫生时对她动手动脚，当她没有性趣时就生闷气。到2004年10月，辛迪已经受够了。她从未爱过罗伯特，并告诉他她想离婚。分居后，罗伯特跟踪辛迪，一天到晚开车从她家门前驶过。他开始对她新的恋情产生执念，一想到另一个男人会成为他儿子的父亲形象就愤怒不已。
Yet, he refused to look after the boys when Cindy needed a babysitter, including on one occasion when she had to go to hospital. He made menacing threats, saying things like, I've got contacts, don't underestimate me. On the night of September 1, four days before her sons died, Robert called Cindy at home. Throughout the conversation, Cindy noticed that he sounded very depressed. She was concerned enough that she mentioned it to Stephen's mother, who advised her to just watch out. But Cindy had never dreamed that her boys might be in danger.
然而，当辛迪需要临时保姆时，他却拒绝照顾男孩们，包括有一次她不得不去医院。他发出威胁，说一些“我有人脉，别低估我”之类的话。9月1日晚上，也就是她儿子们死前四天，罗伯特给家里的辛迪打电话。在整个谈话过程中，辛迪注意到他听起来非常沮丧。她感到很担忧，便把这事告诉了史蒂芬的母亲，对方劝她多加留意。但辛迪做梦也没有想到她的儿子们会有危险。
She suspected that Robert was suicidal, not homicidal. Cindy continued to believe in Robert's innocence throughout his trial, though she was troubled by Greg's testimony. It didn't make sense that a close friend of Robert's would come forward with such a story if it wasn't true. When she heard Robert had won his appeal, Cindy didn't feel relieved at all. She began to realize that perhaps she'd been in denial about her ex-husband's role in their son's deaths.
她怀疑罗伯特有自杀倾向，而不是有谋杀倾向。在审判期间，辛迪仍然相信罗伯特的清白，尽管格雷格的证词让她感到不安。罗伯特的亲密朋友如果不是真的发生过这种事，是不太可能编造出这样的故事的。当她听说罗伯特上诉成功时，辛迪一点也没有感到放松。她开始意识到，也许她一直在否认前夫在他们儿子死亡中所扮演的角色。
When Detective Clanchy called to tell her that a witness had come forward, she decided to provide police with a new statement. This time, she'd reveal some things she'd previously kept hidden about her ex-husband. The next time Cindy said eyes on Robert was when she walked into Victoria's Supreme Court for his retrial on May 4, 2010. Cindy and her supporters all wore her trademark shade of purple, and her hair was streaked with violet highlights. When she took the stand, she spoke openly about the problems before, during and after
当克兰奇侦探打电话告诉她有目击者出面时，这一次，她决定向警方提供一份新的陈述。她将透露一些以前对前夫隐瞒的事情。辛迪下一次见到罗伯特是在2010年5月4日，当时她走进维多利亚州最高法院参加他的重审。辛迪和她的支持者们都穿着她标志性的紫色，她的头发上也挑染了紫罗兰色。当她走上证人席时，她公开谈论了之前、期间和之后的各种问题
her marriage. Several times, she glanced at Robert. Her expression grew angry when she was asked to identify him as her children's father. When the defense grilled Cindy on why she was changing her stance after initially supporting Robert, she replied, I've had five years to think about this. He killed my kids. Dawn also testified about what she'd seen on the night of the accident.
她的婚姻。有好几次，她瞥了罗伯特一眼。当她被要求指认他为孩子们的父亲时，她的表情变得愤怒。当辩方盘问辛迪，为什么她在最初支持罗伯特后又改变立场时，她回答说：“我有五年的时间来考虑这件事。他杀了我孩子。”唐也就在事故当晚看到的情况作了证。
Robert Farquharson hadn't taken the stand during his previous trial, but at his retrial, he was the defense's first witness. He fidgeted awkwardly as he swore on a Bible. His small stature seemed exaggerated by the formal shirt and tie he was wearing. He refused to look at Cindy. Robert repeated his story about having a coughing fit and waking to find the car bobbing in the dam. Although Dawn's testimony indicated all three boys were squashed together in the back of
罗伯特·法夸尔森在之前的审判中没有出庭作证，但在重审时，他是辩方的第一位证人。他在对着圣经发誓时局促不安。他矮小的身材在所穿的正式衬衫和领带衬托下显得有些夸张。他拒绝看着辛迪。罗伯特重复了他关于咳嗽发作并醒来发现汽车在水库中漂浮的说法。尽管唐的证词表明三个男孩都挤在汽车后座上
the car, Robert insisted that Jay had been sitting beside him in the front passenger seat. He was unable to answer a number of questions, claiming he couldn't recall some details or wasn't sure of certain things. Under cross-examination, the prosecution asked why Robert hadn't tried harder to free his children. Why hadn't he leaned across the back seat to undo two-year-old Bailey's booster seat? Robert simply answered,
但罗伯特坚称杰伊一直坐在他旁边的前排乘客座位上。他对许多问题无法回答，声称自己记不清一些细节或对某些事情不确定。在盘问下，控方询问为什么罗伯特没有更努力地解救他的孩子。为什么他没有跨过后座去解开两岁巴里的增高座椅？罗伯特简单地回答说：
I probably had no thought process. He wasn't sure how the rear doors had come to be locked, but suggested Bailey might have inadvertently switched them off by playing with the latch. Robert said he'd seen Jay open the passenger door, causing water to flood the car, even though the headlights were off and it was pitch black. He couldn't say how or when the lights were switched off. The prosecution suggested he'd turned them off to prevent the car from being easily found. He denied this, now insisting that they and the ignition were both on when they landed
“我可能没有思考过程。”他记不清后车门是如何被锁上的，但暗示巴里可能在玩弄门闩时无意中关上了。罗伯特说，他看到杰伊打开了乘客车门，导致水涌入车内，尽管当时大灯是关着的，外面漆黑一片。他说不出灯是如何或何时被关掉的。控方暗示他关掉车灯是为了防止车辆轻易被找到。他否认了这一点，现在坚称当车子落入水中时，车灯和点火开关都是打开的
in the water. The prosecution asked, Is there any person in the car who could possibly have turned off the ignition other than you? Well, Jay could have easily, said Robert. The jury looked shocked. The prosecution responded, Are you seriously suggesting that one of your children, in the moments before they died, would have had any reason to turn off the ignition of that car?
在水中。控方问道：“车里除了你之外，还有谁可能关掉点火开关？”罗伯特说：“嗯，杰伊很容易就能做到。”陪审团看起来很震惊。控方回应道：“你是说真的吗？你的孩子在死前的几分钟里，会有任何理由去关掉那辆车的点火开关？”
Robert protested that he was simply trying to answer as best as he could. He had no reason for wanting it to be dark out in the dam. After watching Robert's testimony, Cindy had no doubt that he'd avoided her because he was lying. She was disgusted by him. It seemed as though he lacked any remorse. The trial concluded on July 19 and the jury left to deliberate. At 4.50pm on July 22, it was announced that they'd come to a verdict.
罗伯特抗辩说，他只是在尽力回答。他没有任何理由希望水库外面是黑暗的。看完罗伯特的证词后，辛迪毫不怀疑他一直在躲避她，因为他在撒谎。她对感到厌恶。他似乎毫无悔意。审判于7月19日结束，陪审团退庭评议。7月22日下午4点50分，宣布他们已达成裁决。
The date would have been Tyler's 12th birthday if he was still alive. To Cindy, this was a positive omen. Once again, Robert Farquherson was found guilty on all counts. This time, Cindy turned to the jury and mouthed the words, Thank you. Almost three months later, Robert was sentenced to life imprisonment with a 33-year minimum. The judge told the court that in his 38 years of practicing law, this was a case that defied imagination, as the victims were three vulnerable, helpless, and wholly innocent children who had suffered a terrifying death.
如果泰勒还活着，这一天本该是他的12岁生日。对辛迪来说，这是一个积极的预兆。罗伯特·法夸尔森再次被判所有罪名成立。这一次，辛迪转向陪审团，用口型说出“谢谢你们”。将近三个月后，罗伯特被判处无期徒刑，最低服刑33年。法官在法庭上表示，在他38年的法律执业生涯中，这是一起不可思议的案件，因为受害者是三个脆弱、无助且完全无辜的孩子，他们经历了一场可怕的死亡。
Addressing Robert directly, he stated, Your crimes have devastated a significant number of people. Primary among them is your ex-wife, Cindy Gambino, the mother of these three children. Robert shook his head throughout his sentencing. When he was let out of the courtroom, Cindy began to cry. Outside, she told reporters, It's never going to be enough. It's a life sentence for me. It should be a life sentence for him.
在直接对罗伯特说话时，他说：“你的罪行给大量的人带来了毁灭性的打击。首当其冲的是你的前妻辛迪·甘比诺，这三个孩子的母亲。”罗伯特在整个宣判过程中一直摇着头。当他被带出法庭时，辛迪哭了起来。在外面，她告诉记者：“这永远都不够。对我来说这是无期徒刑。对他来说也应该是无期徒刑。”
In August 2013, Robert Farquherson lost his final appeal. In the years after her children's deaths, Cindy Gambino was on the receiving end of abuse from the public. At first, she received letters from people calling her stupid for supporting Robert. Others blamed her for having driven her ex to kill. On one occasion, a man approached her in the supermarket and asked, What did you do to him to make him do that to you? But Cindy also received strong support, encouragement and countless messages from people who empathised
2013年8月，罗伯特·法夸尔森失去了最后一次上诉机会。在孩子们死后的几年里，辛迪·甘比诺遭到了公众的辱骂。起初，她收到人们的信件，称她支持罗伯特很愚蠢。还有人指责她逼迫前夫杀人。有一次，一个男子在超市接近她并问：“你对他做了什么，让他对你做出那种事？”但辛迪也得到了强有力的支持、鼓励以及无数共情者的信息
with her pain. In 2010, she married Stephen Miles. The couple have two children together. The murders of Jay, Tyler and Bailey Farquherson and the subsequent legal proceedings garnered nationwide attention and were widely covered by Australia's media. In 2013, crime journalist Megan Norris published a book about the case titled On Father's Day. Norris had previously written about a number of other cases in which men murdered their children during the course of marriage breakdown.
伴随着她的痛苦。2010年，她与史蒂芬·迈尔斯结婚。两人育有两子。杰伊、泰勒和巴里·法夸尔森的谋杀案以及随后的法律诉讼引起了全国范围的关注，并受到澳大利亚媒体的广泛报道。2013年，犯罪记者梅根·诺里斯出版了一本关于此案的书，名为《父亲节那天》。诺里斯此前曾撰写过其他几起案件，都是关于父亲在婚姻破裂期间谋杀自己孩子的。
She spent lots of time with Cindy while working on the book and tells much of the story from Cindy's perspective. The following year, author Helen Garner released her book, This House of Grief, which shares her thoughts and experiences from attending both trials. Cindy has initiated legal action to prevent Robert from being buried in the spot he purchased alongside their son's burial plot and her own grave. In an interview with the Herald's son, she explained, I'd be mortified if my boys and I had to be buried with him.
她在创作这本书时花了很多时间陪伴辛迪，并主要从辛迪的角度讲述了整个故事。第二年，作家海伦·加纳出版了她的书《这座悲伤的房子》，其中分享了她参加两次审判的想法和经历。辛迪已经提起法律诉讼，阻止罗伯特被埋葬在他购买的与他们儿子墓地和她自己的墓地相邻的地点。在接受《先驱报》儿子的采访时，她解释说：“如果我的男孩们和我必须和他合葬，我会感到羞耻的。”
I will move the boys and myself if I have to. People go to all sorts of extremes for things they believe in. The night he murdered our boys, he lost every right to be near them. Jay, Tyler and Bailey share a large marble headstone at the Winchelsea Cemetery. It features oval portrait photographs of the three boys. On the top left-hand side is a gold logo of the Essendon Football Club, the Australian Rules Team beloved by both Jay and Tyler. On the other side is an etching of Bob the Builder from Bailey's favourite television
如果必须的话，我会把男孩们和我自己迁走。人们为了他们信仰的事物会走向各种极端。在他谋杀我们男孩的那天晚上，他失去了靠近他们的所有权利。杰伊、泰勒和巴里在温奇尔海公墓共用一块巨大的大理石墓碑。上面有三个男孩的椭圆形肖像照片。左上角是埃森登澳式足球俱乐部的金色标志，这是杰伊和泰勒都喜爱的澳式足球队。另一边是巴里最喜欢的电视剧中“修理工鲍勃”的蚀刻画
show. Beneath the boys' names are the words, much loved and cherished children of Robert and Cindy. In 2010, when Robert was out on bail following his first appeal, someone used a chisel or a similar tool to scratch his name off the headstone, leaving rough gouges in the marble. It isn't known who was responsible for doing this. He has resisted calls from Robert's family to have his name, Reign stated. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
节目。男孩们的名字下面写着：“罗伯特和辛迪深爱且珍视的孩子们。”2010年，罗伯特在第一次上诉后保释出狱时，有人用凿子或类似工具将他的名字从墓碑上刮掉，在大理石上留下了粗糙的凹痕。目前尚不清楚是谁干的。他拒绝了罗伯特家人的要求，称其名字已被划掉。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。